du jour appelle le débat sur la réforme
des retraites et la pénibilité ce débat
a été demandé par le groupe écolo ni
baisse à la demande de ce dernier se
tient salle Lamartine afin que des
personnalités extérieures puissent être
interrogées la Conférence des Présidents
a décidé d'organiser ce débat en deux
parties nous commencerons par une table
ronde en présence de personnalités d'une
durée d'une heure puis nous procéderons
après avoir entendu une intervention
liminaire du gouvernement à une nouvelle
conséquence de questions-réponses d'une
durée d'une heure également la durée des
questions et des réponses sera limitée à
deux minutes sans droit de réplique
pour la première phase du débat je
souhaite la bienvenue à Madame Anne
loseig aide-soignante
madame bonjour monsieur André Bouchut
représentant de la Confédération
paysanne et Madame Catherine del Goulet
professeur aux Conservatoire national
des arts et métiers titulaires de la
chair d'ergonomie madame bonjour je vais
donner maintenant la parole à chacun de
nos invités pour une intervention
d'environ cinq minutes chacun la parole
est donc à Madame Anne Losec
bonjour à tout le monde alors je vous
remercie pour l'invitation je suis un
peu intime midi j'ai pas l'habitude
d'intervenir dans ces lieux là alors je
suis la présidente du Collectif la force
invisible des aides à domicile je suis
pas aide-soignante mais assistante de
vie
ce métier a plusieurs appellations
assistantes de vie auxiliaire de vie
aide à domicile
c'est un métier vital à la cohésion
sociale un métier du prendre soin qui ne
laisse pas la place à la robotique c'est
un métier où nous sommes 95% de femmes
soit 40% qui ont moins de 30 ans 60% qui
ont 50 ans
nous avons 70% de temps partiel subit ou
choisi
nous avons un taux de précarité de
17,5%. précarité d'emplois précarité de
logement précarité financière précarité
alimentaire nous avons un salaire moyen
de moins de 1000 euros
nous avons deux pénibilités nous avons
la pénibilité physique et la pénibilité
des risques psycho
psychosociaux
alors la pénibilité physique nous sommes
le premier secteur accidentogène devant
le BTP
53% sont dues à la manutention manuelle
parce que nous avons des humains entre
nos mains nous les bougeons nous les
transférons du lit au fauteuil nous leur
faisons des toilettes
nous avons des charges lourdes comme les
courses qu'on peut porter monter au
sixième étage sans ascenseur
nous on nous demande de lever de levain
matelas on nous demande de bouger les
meubles pour faire le ménage
et
tout ça souvent sans matériel adapté
c'est à dire que pour lever une personne
on le fait avec nos bras alors que ça
soit un corps qui pèse 40 kg ou un corps
qui pèse 80 kg on le fait avec nos bras
on a des du matériel adapté mais il est
pas obligatoire ou domicile soit il
refusait par la personne aider soit il
est refusé par la famille soit il y en a
mais on sait pas s'en servir parce qu'on
n'est pas formé pour
nous avons aussi 35 % de chute à
domicile alors les chutes sont dues au
déplacement
de mobilité parce que il y en a qui se
qui se
qui vont en vélo donc accident de la
route
en trottinette qui tombe accident de la
route on tombe aussi avec les
bénéficiaires les personnes qu'on prend
en charge pour éviter et
qu'elles aient encore plus mal donc
c'est nous qui nous mettons qui mettons
le corps en avant pour éviter ces avoir
plus de blessures
nous avons aussi
[Musique]
des
une charge mentale
émotionnelle qui est très importantes
parce que nous allons de domicile en
domicile et chaque domicile a une
pathologie différente
nous avons
des pathologies ou il y a de
lagressivité nous avons des pathologies
où on a une détresse psychologique voire
psychique
nous avons
[Musique]
des des situations et je vais prendre
mon cas personnel de fin de vie où on
vient chez la personne on ne sait pas
que c'est une fin de vie et on prend
toute la violence que ça peut avoir pour
la professionnelle pour la famille et
c'est nous qui la prenons on
l'accompagne jusqu'au dernier souffle et
après on accompagne aussi parfois la
famille dans les démarches
administratives et quand je vous parle
de violence émotionnelle c'est que on
accompagne sans être formé à la fin de
vie les soins palliatifs
c'est tout un accompagnement qui doit
être
spécifique à la personne spécifique à
l'aidant parce que forcément quand on
est dans un domicile et quand il y a un
aidant et quand il y a une fin de vie
on accompagne aussi les dents pour
pour
ces derniers instants avec la personne
je vais vous demander de conclure Madame
le sexe s'il vous plaît alors nous
sommes alors je vais conclure le
maintien à domicile on travaille avec de
l'humain on est une pédigibilité énorme
on est les précaires d'aujourd'hui on
sera les précaires de demain et pour la
retraite à 64 ans le corps ne pourra pas
suivre
voilà c'est vraiment le corps on est
vraiment à 50 ans une auxiliaire de vie
est déjà fatiguée
merci cette intervention la parole est à
Monsieur André Bouchut
bonjour merci de l'invitation donc je
représente la Confédération paysanne
aujourd'hui sachant qu'on est en place
alors l'agriculture donc de nombreux
responsables nationaux sont déjà pris
par le salon de l'agriculture
donc on va parler des différentes
agricultures parce qu'il y a plein
d'agriculture différentes différents
métiers et différentes pénibilités et je
terminerai par deux interpellations
concernant le sujet qui
qui est en débat aujourd'hui donc je
j'étais j'étais puisque je suis à la
retraite j'ai bénéficié de la retraite à
60 ans au bout de 43 ans de travail donc
j'ai fait partie des gens qui en ont
bénéficié j'étais paysan par la Loire
dans le monde du Lyonnais producteur de
champignons et de myrtilles et fils
d'éleveur donc je connais relativement
bien les métiers j'ai été pendant très
longtemps responsable national
donc alors l'agriculture ou les
agricultures il y a des fermes qui sont
très petites d'autres qui sont très
grandes donc c'est pas la même
agriculture il y a une agriculture avec
des animaux qui génèrent certains nombre
de risques d'autres qui sont sans
animaux et des agriculture qui sont
robotisées d'autres qui sont mécanisés
d'autres qui sont manuelles donc chaque
fois on a des métiers très différents
on a des agriculteurs qui se font en
intérieur d'autres en extérieur en
intérieur c'est des porcheries c'est des
choses de ce style là ça peut être
dessert ça peut être des salles de
production de champignons par exemple et
en extérieur on connaît plus alors les
différents métiers et c'est là où ça
devient très compliqué au niveau de
l'agriculture c'est que on peut être
producteur on est producteur en premier
mais après on est comptable on est
gestueux d'art d'une entreprise on est
gestionnaire de salariés
on m'a de plus en plus d'informatique
donc ça veut dire qu'on a plein de
métiers à gérer et ça devient
extrêmement complexe et tous ces métiers
à gérer toutes ces différents types de
production génèrent des pénibilités
alors deux types de pénibilité c'est
comme la personne qui est intervenue
avant le premier c'est les problèmes
physiques alors ce qu'on appelle les TMS
chez nous les trucs muscoloscoliques
donc bien entendu la conduite d'engin
qui provoque souvent des grosses
douleurs dans le dos
l'élevage ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
industriel
quand il faut passer le karcher des
journées entières dans une porscherie
c'est assez pénible les bovins qui ont
induisent beaucoup de d'accidents des
ovins qui sont très meurtriers pour le
dos parce qu'il faut attraper les ovins
et donc c'est très très meurtrier de ce
côté là des gestes répétitifs on a
beaucoup de tendinites des problèmes de
canal carpien moi je faisais du
champignon j'ai plusieurs salariés qui
ont été opérés du canal carpien par
exemple le dos pour le maraîchage parce
que la terre est toujours basse
les travaux forestiers
qui sont sans doute le métier qui amène
le plus accident du travail
et puis une remarque particulière sur la
question des femmes parce que
l'ergonomie des matérielle n'est souvent
pas adaptée aux femmes donc je pense
qu'il y a une nécessité peut-être à
modifier la loi pour faire en sorte que
les gens
pour que les femmes le matériel soit
plus adaptés qu'on trouve des solutions
là-dessus
et puis tout après les autres problèmes
sont psychologiques donc les fameux TPS
les troupes psychosociaux alors ils sont
dû à une multitude de choses aujourd'hui
on nous demande de produire toujours
plus donc d'investir de plus donc de
s'endetter plus c'est extrêmement lourd
donc le poids de la dette sur les fermes
c'est extrêmement lourd aujourd'hui les
risques d'aller à climatiques on les
voit arriver de plus en plus l'année
qu'on vient de vivre et puis l'hiver
avec le problème de l'eau ça veut dire
que ça met une pression énorme
j'ai croisé des producteurs de fruits
qui sont très très inquiets pour l'année
à venir
les risques revenus parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a un tiers des paysans qui ont
un revenu si on peut parler de revenus
quand on est à 300 ou 400 euros la
question des pesticides parce qu'il y a
une pression sociétale
il y a le risque de maladies et le
paysan là en lui donc en disant parfois
je crois que j'utilise mais il faudrait
peut-être pas ma santé qu'est-ce que ça
va donner donc on a vraiment des gros
soucis aujourd'hui on va nous demander
de faire des traitements de nuit ça veut
dire qu'on supprime la nuit pour aller
traiter est-ce que ça acceptable
des durées de journées de travail qui
sont très très longues la complexité
administrative avec toute la
dématérialisation aujourd'hui
50% des paysans sont fâchés avec tout ça
enfin ils n'y arrivent plus moi j'ai
rencontré plusieurs personnes dans la
préparation de ce débat qui m'ont dit
même nous qui sommes jeunes même nous
qui avons formé qui ont des bêtes qui
avons des BTS voir des formations
d'ingénieurs
on bataille en patine devant toute cette
dématérialisation toute cette complexité
administrative aujourd'hui sur tous les
métiers qui utilisent des saisonniers on
trouve de moins en moins de saisonniers
c'est très compliqué à gérer
et puis on dit on va robotiser on va
automatiser oui pourquoi pas mais quand
on a une de l'irrigation qui est
automatisée pour un domaine que je
connais très bien par exemple mais il
faut surveiller en continu ça veut dire
que ça enlève pas le stress donc il y a
énormément
de stress qui existe et puis la porte
tombée malade donc toutes ces choses là
génère du stress de la fatigue la
dépression et malheureusement le milieu
agricole on détient un triste record des
suicides donc ça veut dire que c'est
très très grave alors comment faire moi
j'ai deux questions à vous poser il y en
a un qui est pendant le cours de la vie
professionnelle c'est il est
indispensable de faciliter la
reconnaissance des TMS et des TPs parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le parcours du
combattant on va voir un médecin la
médecine du travail enfin la médecine de
la MSA ça ne fonctionne pas et le
deuxième c'est sur la question du compte
pénibilité qui sera difficilement
envisageable au niveau des paysans parce
que ce sera encore au niveau trop
complexe mais peut-être on pourrait vous
pourriez imaginer quelque chose comme un
système de pénibilité par ROTEX par type
de production là il y aura un travail de
fond à faire et qui permettrait d'avoir
un gain de trimestre donc c'est vraiment
deux choses facilité la reconnaissance
de maladie d'accident du travail et
deuxièmement aller vers la question de
la pénibilité par au texte et travail
là-dessus c'est à dire de dire assez
réaliers n'a pas les mêmes problèmes
qu'un éleveur qu'un maraîcher
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Catherine
delgoulet
oui merci bonjour à toutes et à tous et
merci de cette invitation
mon propos liminaire visera à brosser
les facettes de la pénibilité dans déjà
les deux personnes avant moi ont parlé
et de voir comment cette approche
finalement de la santé au travail pose
un certain nombre de questions et puis
je finirai par
discuter sur une notion celle de la
soutenabilité du travail qui me semble
être intéressante pour aborder les
enjeux qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui
d'une manière un peu différente donc
quand on s'intéresse aux questions de
pénibilité du travail les travaux
scientifiques finalement pressent qu'il
n'y a pas une pénibilité mais des
facettes de la pénibilité au moins 4
alors il y a des pénibilités
objectivables c'est ce sont les
pénibilités du travail que l'on retrouve
notamment à l'occasion la réforme des
retraites de 2010 et qui a donné une
définition toujours en vigueur d'une
pénibilité qui se caractérise par
l'exposition du travailleur un ou
plusieurs facteurs de risque
professionnels liés à des contraintes
physiques marquées à un environnement
physique agressif mais aussi à certains
nombres de rythmes de travail qui sont
susceptibles de laisser des traces
durables
identifiables et irréversible sur la
santé et ce décret a donné lieu à
l'identification à une liste de 10
facteurs de la pénibilité repris dans le
compte C3P et ensuite réduit en 2017 au
seul six critères qui demeure
aujourd'hui mais à côté de cette
pénibilité d'une partie de cette
pénibilité objectivable il y a aussi une
seconde facette qui est celle d'un
ensemble de conditions de travail
considérés comme des contraintes connues
comme délétères que sont notamment les
contraintes psychosociales dont il a été
question juste avant ou un certain
nombre de contraintes organisations
liées notamment à la pression temporelle
là aussi qui a été
souligner juste avant et qui sont
sources de troubles infra pathologiques
importants aujourd'hui en France
à ces deux premières facettes s'ajoutent
également une autre deux autres facettes
qui sont celles des pénibilités vécues
ou pénibilité au travail du fait
notamment d'une santé fragilisée dont la
probabilité augmente avec l'avancée en
âge mais aussi une pénibilité au travail
du fait de conditions de travail et
d'organisation mal vécu qui vont avoir
une incidence sur le souhait de quitter
son travail et là je renvoie aux
difficultés de recrutement dans un
certain nombre de métiers aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui la seule partie de la
pénibilité objectivable et considérer
dans les les éléments réglementaires au
regard des six critères du C2P et cette
manière finalement de considérer la
pénibilité pose me semble-t-il quatre
types de questions que je vais très
rapidement évoqué et sur lesquels on
pourra revenir si vous le souhaitez
premièrement les critères de pénibilité
et leur seuil aujourd'hui très élevé ne
concerne fort heureusement qu'une
population réduite est très particulière
soumise à des sollicitations extrêmes et
sur de très longues durées les derniers
chiffres de l'assurance maladie le
confirme en 2021 cela concernait un peu
moins de 650
000 salariés la plupart les trois quarts
étant des hommes et 45% des personnes
travaillant en secteur de l'industrie
manufacturière
deuxième question ou remarque sur cette
approche des pénibilités et bien c'est
que la réforme prévoit par ailleurs
d'abaisser le seuil d'exposition de ces
6 critères et de supprimer la limite des
points cumulables sur une carrière alors
comme le dit Ford justement une collègue
Annie Jolivet économiste au Centre
d'études de l'emploi du CNAM c'est une
mesure à double tranchant cela peut
renvoyer le message que la durée
finalement d'exposition n'est pas grave
puisqu'on peut gagner des points mais
c'est oublier que lorsqu'on cumule des
points aussi cela a des conséquences sur
la santé le troisième élément c'est que
la réforme prévoit également un suivi
médical renforcé pour
sur un certain nombre de facteurs de
risque dit ergonomique alors je
travaille sur l'oxymore de mon point de
vue du risque ergonomique en tant
qu'ergonome je ne valide absolument pas
cette figure de style mais je reviendrai
également sur la création donc de ces
visites obligatoires de fin de carrière
à 61 ans ou au final l'idée est de
repérer les les personnes qui ne sont
pas en mesure de continuer de travailler
pour leur permettre de partir à 62 ans
ici on finalement on décale et on
s'éloigne de la définition légale de la
pénibilité qui mentionne des risques
professionnels et non pas des
incapacités déjà avérées enfin dernier
point la question du développement des
compétences semble peu traiter alors que
c'est une question il me semble clé pour
justement pouvoir sortir de ces
conditions de travail forcément
délétères mais ce que l'on constate
c'est que d'enquête enquête sur le sujet
et bien on retrouve les mêmes résultats
l'accès à la formation se fait au
détriment des plus âgés et des
catégories socio-professionnelles qui
sont les plus exposées aux pénibilité
les ouvriers et les employés ce sont
donc des population qui se retrouvent
coincées dans des parcours
professionnels aux conditions de travail
difficiles alors pour finir le monde
conclure rapidement voilà je voulais
orienter vers une question qui est que
plutôt finalement de considérer le
travail comme inévitablement pénible et
dans des finir des critères de
pénibilité pourquoi pas
aborder justement la question sous
l'ordre de la soutenabilité du travail
et en faire un principe fondateur du
travail d'aujourd'hui et de demain
merci
merci Madame dès merci à tous les trois
exercices et jamais simple d'intervenir
en 5 minutes mais vous aurez l'occasion
peut-être de compléter avec les
questions
nous en venons donc à cette série de
questions j'invite tous ceux qui le
souhaitent
intervenir dans la table ronde à
s'inscrire auprès de la direction de la
séance chaque question sera
immédiatement suivie de sa réponse pour
que le débat soit le plus fluide
possible et la première question est
posée par Madame Sophie taillée paulion
du groupe écolo nipples à l'initiative
de ce débat merci madame la Présidente
merci infiniment aux trois intervenants
intervenantes pour leurs expériences
leurs vécu je pense que quand nous
échangeons sur la question de la
pénibilité ou des pénibilité nous
manquons bien souvent de témoignages qui
donnent à voir le réel de ce qui est
vécu et notamment d'une diversité de de
gestes de situations de pénibilité qui
sont difficiles à évaluer et difficile
aussi à comptab et on ne peut pas tout
objectiver et c'est bien là aussi l'un
des l'un des problématiques très
importantes finalement du compte
pénibilité même dans sa première version
comment faire pour que l'ensemble des
pénibilités soient prises en compte et
je reviendrai madame delgoulet et vous
permettant peut-être de développer
davantage sur la question de la
soutenabilité du travail qu'est-ce qui
pourrait permettre finalement à ce que
le travail soit vu de manière plus
soutenable est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
prévention de quelle manière elle
pourrait être développée et je pose
également la question aux deux autres
intervenants dans vos métiers qu'est-ce
qu'on devrait faire à la base je dirais
pour faire en sorte que et bien cette
pénibilité elle soit la mieux possible
évitée et puis quand elle n'est pas
évitable parce que certains certaines
ont pu parler
d'exosquelette ou autre formidable
inventions technologiques qui
n'arriveront jamais ou alors quand nous
serons tous décédés dans l'intégralité
des entreprises françaises que peut-on
faire pour faire en sorte que certains
métiers qui sont pénibles par définition
même s'ils sont forts valorisants même
s'ils sont extraordinaires de liens et
de et d'importance sociale que certains
métiers puissent être et bien finalement
comment dirais-je travaillé moins
longtemps et que cela soit finalement un
acquis commun on se dit voilà tel ou tel
métier on pourrait aussi on aurait pu
inviter des égoutiers et bien voilà on
ne peut pas être égouttier toute sa vie
par contre on le paye de son corps et
peut-être une retraite plutôt serait-ce
qu'il y a de mieux
je vous remercie peut-être d'abord la
réponse de Madame delgoulet
éventuellement compléter par les deux
autres intervenants s'il le souhaitent
et réponses est en limitée à deux
minutes
rentrer par ces conditions extrêmes
laisse de côté tout un tas de situations
qui me semblent importantes à considérer
par ailleurs la question de la
pénibilité aujourd'hui est appréhendée
sous le mode de la substitution c'est à
dire que par exemple en substitue les
plus âgés les plus jeunes et donc
finalement au risque d'user
prématurément les plus jeunes voir de
les voir exclus du monde du travail plus
rapidement on le on travaille ces
questions là par la compensation et donc
ici l'idée c'est qu'on capitalise des
points mais là aussi au risque
finalement d'instrumentaliser la santé
et puis enfin on travaille ces questions
de pénibilité par une médicalisation de
la prévention une réparation grâce à des
systèmes d'invalidité ou de retraite
anticipées par incapacité telle que elle
est envisagée dans la dans la prochaine
réforme donc ici il me semble que l'idée
pas seulement d'améliorer de manière
substantielle ces dispositifs
reconnaissant la pénibilité mais
finalement d'attraper les choses
autrement et de les attraper en
s'intéressant justement à la question de
cette soutinidité alors cette
souverainbilité vient c'est quoi c'est
notamment et bien construire des
systèmes de travail qui sont en mesure
de à la fois reproduire et développer
toutes les ressources et les composantes
qu'ils utilisent et donc là ici on est
plus seulement dans la substitution la
compensation ou la réparation mais dans
le prendre soin des choses des personnes
dans la durée ça veut dire penser à des
parcours et également s'intéresser à la
question de la transmission et de
l'organisation de la succession
je vous remercie est-ce que Monsieur
bochou Madame le sexe souhaite compléter
oui monsieur Baucher vous avez la parole
oui juste quelques points par rapport à
votre question
pour nous il faut arrêter cette fuite en
avant de toujours plus toujours plus de
volume toujours plus d'investissement
j'en ai parlé mais je crois que c'est
très important je prends un exemple je
vois qu'elle député de la
circonscription qui connaît très bien
l'élevage à l'étang
quand j'ai démarré ma carrière il y a
une quarantaine d'années
il fallait 40 ou 45 vaches allaitantes
pour vivre aujourd'hui il en faut 80-90
il y a toujours un actif chaque vache
fait un veau donc chaque fois il se
démêlage enfin c'est à dire que c'est
d'élever la c'est le travail la nuit
enfin c'est très compliqué cette moi
j'appelle ça vraiment une fuite en avant
parce qu'on se rend pas compte en disant
aujourd'hui vous aviez ça mais acheter
du matériel plus gros acheter des
acheter un ordinateur qui va surveiller
vos vaches non la pression elle est là
l'ordinateur il verra qu'il y avait là
peut-être mais c'est pas aussi simple
que ça
le deuxième point c'est vraiment il faut
que l'État arrête de se désengager
des exemples je parle des exemples parce
que c'est souvent plus concret par
exemple quand il a fallu passer l'ADSN
au niveau des feuilles de paye avant on
pouvait faire des feuilles de pêche
chacun pourrait faire sa feuille de paie
aujourd'hui on le fil au comptable on
fait toutes ces choses-là c'est à dire
tout à coup on cède
tout est dématérialisé demain toutes les
factures devront être par informatique
c'est à dire on complexifie et quand on
est paysan on n'a pas forcément toutes
ces compétences on est on n'est pas les
moyens d'être compétent de partout donc
il faut arrêter cette fuite il faut
arrêter cette chose là les tasses des
engage en finance à autre chose et puis
le dernier point
on exposait au marché à tout vent c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a une
concurrence internationale en continu on
nous dit vous devez être aussi
compétitif que des Espagnols qui ont un
SMIC à la moitié d'une autre on dit
qu'on doit être aussi compétitif que
d'autres c'est-à-dire qu'on est ouvert à
tous les vents et toujours en pleine
concurrence surtout avec des règles du
jeu qui sont différentes dans chaque
pays dans chaque coin du monde et nous
on nous dit bah vous débrouillez soyez
compétitifs c'est pas vrai ça ne marche
pas les paysans disent comment on peut
faire et ils arrêtent et les jeunes ne
veulent pas reprendre mon fils qui
reprit ne ferme en fruits en fruits dit
aujourd'hui il y a plus de jeunes qui
veulent s'installer il faut se poser des
questions en fruits aujourd'hui on
produit un tiers du camp consomme en
France il faut se poser des questions
je vous remercie madame le sec vous avez
la parole
alors
pour nous la pénibilité elle peut être
réduite
par de la prévention
c'est à dire de d'avoir des formations
adaptées aux pathologies d'avoir été
créé de sas de décompression quand on
est à l'hôpital quand il y a une fin de
vie ou de l'agressivité il y a une
cellule psychologique et mis en place
chez nous non dans le domicile il y en a
pas c'est aussi de prendre soin des
emplois du temps des emplois du temps
c'est à dire éviter de nous les changer
tous les matins
de nous les alourdir
dans la journée c'est aussi de prendre
en compte les les compétences de chaque
professionnel c'est à dire de pas nous
mettre chez des personnes qui avec qui
on n'a pas d'affinité
professionnelle c'est à dire je vais
vous prendre un exemple
moi la maladie de char j'ai du mal
et
je préfère l'handicap mental mais voilà
c'est reconnaître mes compétences dans
l'handicap mental et éviter de me mettre
en difficulté
vis-à-vis de la personne aider parce que
forcément je me sentirai beaucoup moins
professionnel et ça ça aborde la
pénibilité chez la violence chez la
personne parce que moi je me sens moins
professionnelle mais gestes seront moins
assurés et voilà c'est de reconnaître la
compétence aussi de la professionnelle
et de son avis c'est ensuite aussi de
donner un peu plus d'autonomie dans la
gestion des emplois du temps aux
professionnels et de respecter aussi la
vie privée
des personnes qu'on ne soit pas
corps et jouable à l'employeur
ça c'est ça c'est très important et
surtout qu'on est on est très féminin
95% et la plupart
monoparentale donc c'est très difficile
d'allier
la vie professionnelle avec la vie
personnelle c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
temps partiels choisis parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement pour élever nos
enfants et ça aussi ça fait partie de la
pénibilité parce que on culpabilise on
n'a pas de progression professionnelle
et ça on devrait prendre ça aussi en
compte
je vous remercie pour la prochaine
question la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
d'arrivine pour le groupe GDR nups
merci madame la Présidente merci de vos
interventions sur sur ce sujet
extrêmement important à nos yeux
d'abord je voudrais commencer par une
une question
assez simple et directe sur le recours à
l'invalidité aussi au système de
d'invalidité depuis les fenêtres depuis
où nous parlez comment est-ce que vous
regardez ce dispositif son usage ses
conséquences dans les expériences que
vous avez pu faire et constater autour
de vous
deuxième question peut-être un peu plus
vaste concernant
l'équilibre entre prévention réparation
et compensation
il est évident qu'il y a beaucoup
d'efforts à faire pour traiter le mal à
la source pour s'attaquer aux maladies
éliminable et donc la prévention à la
matière est décisive
et je partage qui a été dit il y a
quelques instants il y a sans doute
beaucoup de choses à changer on sent
qu'il faut changer de système mais en
tout cas au moins beaucoup de choses à
changer dans le système ou dans les
systèmes pour mieux respecter le travail
mettre fin à cette course à la
rentabilité à la concurrence permanente
de tout ce qu'entre tous et l'idée que
le marché va bien s'occuper de tout ça
bien il y a aussi un deuxième aspect qui
est celui de mieux respecter les métiers
les différents métiers qui a été évoqué
à l'instant ne faut-il pas imaginer en
tout cas dans un certain nombre de lieux
de pouvoir donner peut-être plus de
travail à celles et ceux qui travaillent
sur leur geste sur leur travail sur la
détermination de l'organisation du du
travail lui-même ma première question et
la deuxième toujours dans le même champ
parce que je crois que la compensation
est nécessaire
et que le risque de ne parler que de
prévention pour éviter d'avoir à parler
de compensation il faut l'éviter
et donc en termes de compensation
comment voyez-vous qu'on puisse
objectiver les situations pour établir
des droits collectifs parce que sans
droit collectif je crois qu'il n'y aura
pas de droit individuel
merci beaucoup qui souhaite répondre
monsieur Bouchut
e
aujourd'hui le constat en agriculture
c'est que c'est très très compliqué
c'est un parcours du combattant les
médecins généralistes
acceptent très difficilement de rentrer
dans ces parcours là et après la
mutualité sociale agricole les médecins
qui ne sont censés nous suivre ils
rentrent encore très très difficilement
donc souvent quand les gens ont ça ils
sont on s'est maladies on s'est problème
déjà c'est difficile de le reconnaître
on a des métiers où il y a une sorte
d'omerthasme c'est pas facile de
reconnaître qu'on va pas bien qu'on est
qu'on a des difficultés qu'on a trop de
charges que ça va ce que c'est difficile
donc quand on accepte de faire la
démarche que quelqu'un nous a poussé
nous a aidé à la faire quand on va voir
le médecin qui dit ouais oui oui on va
voir la médecine du travail oui oui donc
ça veut dire je pense que vous en tant
qu'assemblée nationale vous avez à vous
saisir cette question là à faire comment
la médecine s'empare ça et accepte quand
un paysan dit je ne vais pas bien une
paysanne je ne vais pas bien de vraiment
regarder des choses en face ça c'est la
première chose c'est pas comment vous
pouvez le prendre je suis pas député
donc je peux pas vous dire ça c'est la
première chose sur la question
d'améliorer les gestes c'est vrai que on
court et on prend pas le temps de se
former pas assez sans doute
alors regardez dans les droits regardez
dans participation regardez dans le dans
le montant des aides qui est attribué au
niveau de l'appareil regardez dans les
différentes aides qui existent comment
on les correlle à une obligation de
formation un obligation d'amélioration
des des métiers des travailleurs parce
que on est souvent dans la fuite en
avant on reproduit ce qu'il y a la
génération en avant à fait et donc
là-dessus
il doit y avoir du travail également
j'ai pas de réponse totalement abouti et
puis la question des droits des droits
collectifs moi je vous ai dit il faut
aller par type de métier
je vous ai dit parrotex c'est-à-dire que
c'est il y a des grandes catégories qui
existent pour définir des choses il faut
sans doute se mettre autour d'une table
avec tous les gens qui sont dans les
différents métiers de dire il y a
l'élevage
les quais l'élevage bovins à l'étang il
y a le maraîchage chaque type de métier
génère
pour moi une part importante des des
risques et des maladies donc il faut les
traiter et dire si j'ai fait si j'ai été
maraîcher pendant 30 ans bah ça me donne
droit à 6 mois un an deux ans de de
retraite préventive par exemple enfin il
faut travailler là-dessus parce que si
on va sur des comptes pénibilité ça sera
des comptes d'apothicaire ça sera
ingérable donc travaillons par les
différents métiers les différentes et ça
on sait faire au niveau de l'agriculture
on a on a des grandes ce texte
merci
en fait j'ai pas grand chose à rajouter
par rapport à vous nous aussi c'est la
même chose
améliorer les gestes faudrait que ça
soit obligatoire dans notre métier parce
que on se blesse très vite un geste est
mal et très vite mal pris et difficile à
l'enlever donc ça les formations elles
doivent être obligations et des
formations en continu
le droit collectif
nous on est on a plusieurs conventions
collectives il serait bien qu'on en ait
qu'une et que la pénibilité soit
reconnue dans dans celle-ci et pour
toutes les auxiliaires de vie quel que
soit le statut juridique dans laquelle
elle travaille
merci Madame delgoules est-ce que vous
souhaitez ajouter un mot oui juste pour
pour dire sur sur cette question
justement des des gestes professionnels
ce que l'on constate c'est que dans
beaucoup de métiers et notamment de
métier pénibles et bien cette question
des gestes professionnels est souvent
déconsidérée et on considère que
finalement c'est un attribut une qualité
des personnes de savoir tenir une pelle
de savoir faire effectivement un soin et
une personne etc et donc on forme pas on
peut ou quand on forme c'est pas
forcément très bien et donc cette
question à la fois de de la formation de
la construction des gestes
professionnels de l'évolution de
celui-ci au fur et à mesure que l'on
avance en âge que l'on avance en
expérience tous ces éléments là sont
fondamentaux me semble-t-il et pose la
question justement de la transmission
et du temps que l'on a pour transmettre
aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de situations
il y en a aucun et celles et ceux qui
souhaitent et acceptent d'endosser le
statut de tuteur et d'accompagnant des
novices qu'ils soient jeunes ou plus
âgés et bien le fond sur leur temps de
travail et donc
en prenant sur d'autres tâches qu'ils
ont ou qu'elles ont à faire en parallèle
et donc c'est ces temps-là sont des
temps précieux des temps ou justement on
construit l'avenir de demain à la fois
du point de vue de des savoir-faire
professionnels mais aussi de la santé et
du geste efficient c'est-à-dire du geste
qui permet à la fois de d'atteindre les
objectifs de performance mais aussi un
geste qui permet de préserver sa santé
mais aussi de la construire donc ça ça
me semble très important
merci pour ces réponses
la parole est à Madame maastrip à nous y
en pouvait pour le groupe Renaissance
bonjour merci pour pour vos
interventions monsieur mesdames
on a on a l'impression en
entendant les débats en écoutant vos
aussi vos interventions que le concept
de pénibilité
a finalement été d'abord pensé pour le
monde industriel et appréhende très mal
tous ces nouveaux secteurs de l'économie
autour des services et je pense
notamment à votre témoignage madame le
service à la personne et la question
donc appréhender pour effectivement des
pénibilités dit objectivable mais moins
des pénibilités qui sont vraiment au
jour le jour et qui sont liés à
l'expérience et aux vécu tel que vous
avez pu très très justement les définir
madame donc ma question c'est
à côté de la soutenabilité qui a été
évoquée par par Madame comment penser
aujourd'hui un compte pénibilité qui
prennent aussi en compte ce monde des
services dans lesquels par ailleurs les
salariés sont moins bien représentés je
pense voilà parce que les secteurs sont
souvent plus plus morcelés la deuxième
chose c'est effectivement l'importance
des gestes professionnels parce que
quand on discute avec des responsables
de ressources humaines qui ont des
activités
identiques en France et dans d'autres
pays européens il y a un taux d'accident
du travail qui est supérieur
pour exactement le même métier et donc
il y a peut-être aussi cette culture de
la du geste professionnel de la
prévention de la sécurité au travail qui
est moins bien appréhendée et enfin là
c'est plutôt une question on vous
parliez de ce concept très intéressant
de soutenabilité madame est-ce qu'il y a
des pays européens qui ont commencé
en particulier dans les législations ou
dans des bonnes pratiques mais peut-être
avec la capacité de la loi
d'avancer sur cette question de la
soutenabilité et qui sont des vrais
exemples de parcours professionnels ou
de reconversion professionnelle voilà
pour penser aussi des évolutions sur
toute une vie merci
merci
qui souhaite répondre
le premier ou la première
merci pour vos questions
alors effectivement aujourd'hui le
compte pénibilité et les critères tels
qu'ils sont identifiés
sont correspondent
au monde de l'industrie plus
particulièrement ça c'est ça c'est
évident
comment considérer et prendre en compte
d'autres types de pénibilité moi ce qui
me semble important est-ce que montre
les
un certain nombre de travaux c'est la
dimension on va dire du dialogue social
sur ces questions là et notamment de la
manière dont on donne la possibilité aux
personnes qui travaillent et à leur
représentant de parler de ces
pénibilités et d'en rendre compte et
donc de construire les ensemble
justement à certains le nombre de
repères qui relèverait justement de ce
secteur des services de ces secteurs des
services et qui pourraient aller au-delà
de ce que l'on peut aujourd'hui et ce
que l'on sait objectiver aujourd'hui ça
ça me semble être important et être une
voix intéressante pour justement via
cette
comment dire ce soutien à la démocratie
sociale en entreprise et bien
construire d'autres voix que celle d'une
pénibilité exclusivement physique
et il me semble que les deux témoignages
ont déjà montré un certain nombre
d'éléments là-dessus forts intéressants
et voilà et qu'il s'agirait de
travailler évidemment mais mais sur
lesquels il me semble qu'il y a de quoi
réfléchir largement
alors sur sur le second point sur la
soutenabilité et la manière dont cette
question là a été travaillée dans
d'autres pays européens alors je ne suis
pas une spécialiste de ces questions là
ce que je sais c'est que cette question
de la soutenabilité a été travaillé dès
la moitié des années 90 par un groupe
piloté par des collègues suédois sur
justement une approche
pluridisciplinaire de ces questions là
et pour cela il se basait notamment sur
des travaux proposés aux Nations Unies
sur le développement durable et c'est à
partir de ces travaux là que pendant une
dizaine d'années ils ont travaillé ces
questions là alors ça a donné dans
certains pays notamment d'Europe du Nord
des possibilités à on va dire prendre
des temps de respiration dans son
parcours professionnel et qui me semble
être notamment dans ces temps de
respiration et bien des manières de
penser autrement les parcours que dans
la pression dont il était question juste
avant
merci beaucoup madame le seigle
alors le conte de pénibilité nous dans
notre dans notre métier on en a pas
donc il faudrait nous par contre en
créer puisque on a une pénibilité
physique et émotionnelle très importante
comment les créer
ben ça c'est autour d'une table qu'on
doit décider avec des médecins avec les
organismes sociaux avec
les auxiliaires les auxiliaires
elles-mêmes avec les dirigeants de
structures
il y a la pénibilité physique
émotionnelle et puis il y a aussi la
pénibilité de nuit parce que j'en ai pas
parlé mais le maintien à domicile c'est
7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24 donc
il y a la pénibilité de nuit qui est pas
comptabilisée non plus si le dirigeant
ne veut pas nous inscrire sur le compte
même pas obligé donc ça c'est une chose
et après on ne rentre pas non plus dans
les cases de pénibilité les charges
lourdes nous c'est pas pris en compte
donc tout ça il faudrait revoir parce
qu'un corps humain qui va comme je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il fasse 40
kilos ou 80 kilos c'est un poids mort
après je dirais aussi que le compte
pénibilité doit être adapté aussi
aux personnes si elles ont été formées
s'il y a
sur sur les gestes et postures parce que
ça ça devrait être une une formation
obligatoire dans nos métiers
une autre obligatoire qui est pas
obligatoire mais qui pour nous et
absurde c'est les premiers secours
alors les gestes postures sont plus ou
moins obligatoires voilà ils le font
parce qu'ils ont un cahier des charges
mais ils peuvent le faire qu'une fois
voilà ils sont pas où ils sont pas dans
l'obligation de le faire plusieurs fois
nous on les réclame tous les deux ans
pour justement
pour apprendre des gestes voilà on
demande aussi pour le compte de
pénibilité d'être vu par des médecins et
là on se heurte comme pour les paysans à
la médecine du travail qui reconnaît qui
reconnaît pas forcément la maladie la
maladie professionnelle et puis aussi la
professionnelle qui ne veut pas dire à
la au médecin du travail dans quelle
détresse ça se trouve parce que elle a
peur de perdre son travail
merci beaucoup monsieur bouchou y
ajouter quelque chose rapidement juste
un tout petit point la question de tous
ces sujets là c'est comment on anticipe
on voit bien que rien à anticiper on
subit nos métiers étaient un petit peu à
part alors je suis pas rentré sur le
sujet des salariés agricoles parce que
j'ai pas forcément la compétence donc je
n'irai pas mais par contre un exemple
nous on a une politique qui était énorme
puisque c'est plus de 9 milliards par an
qui s'appelle la pacte la politique
agricole commune elle met très très peu
d'argent sur l'anticipation on voit bien
que le réchauffement climatique que les
problèmes environnementaux quel que soit
sa vision de la vision des uns et des
autres ces problèmes-là arrivent très
très fortement pourquoi l'impact ne il y
aura pas une part de l'argent ou que
l'argent ne serait pas conditionné à
toute cette prévention tout ce travail
de formation toutes ces choses-là ça
veut dire il y a des moyens on a nous on
est dans un métier où il y a beaucoup
d'argent public qui est mis ce qui veut
pas dire que tout le monde a un bon
revenu loin de là mais il n'empêche
qu'on pourrait travailler sur cette
anticipation conditionner l'un à l'autre
on peut travailler sur les questions
médicales ce qu'on ce qui a été évoqué
plusieurs fois mais aussi sur la
question de l'anticipation et ça on ne
le fait pas
merci la question suivante est posée par
Monsieur Roger judo du groupe
rassemblement national merci Madame
présidente mes chers collègues bienvenue
à nos invités madame lozaigue votre
témoignage
rejoint celui que j'ai recueilli dans ma
permanence pendant la petite trêve des
parlementaire j'ai reçu quatre de vos
collègues syndicalistes de l'ADMR 41
Loir-et-Cher pendant plus d'une heure et
évidemment vos deux discours sont
parfaitement convergents vous êtes les
oubliés du Ségur manifestement ça se
voit notamment à la faiblesse de vos
rémunérations et votre précarité
satutaire par contre vous n'êtes pas
oublié par la projet de loi sur la sur
la retraite qui veut vous faire
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
j'ai retiré de mon entretien avec mes
avec vos collègues le sentiment la
conviction que vous êtes
par le lien social et l'humanité que
vous apportez à nos anciens et aux
Invalides vous êtes le visage de
l'humanité et de la fraternité
donc les questions que je voudrais vous
poser mais en fait elle s'adresserait
davantage au gouvernement s'il était
représenté concerne votre statut ne
croyez-vous pas qu'il serait temps que
le ministère de la Santé et de la
solidarité organise une table ronde
minimum autour du statut des métiers que
vous représentez ici pour les unifier
pour les clarifier pour les définir et
aussi pour les reconnaître alors juste
valeur et sur la retraite je voulais
vous demander à quel âge selon vous quel
serait l'âge acceptable de départ à la
retraite pour pour vos collègues dans
les métiers que vous exercez je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame le sec je vais
demander pour restreindre une réponse de
2 minutes pour qu'on puisse aller
jusqu'au bout merci
alors
nous on dépend pas du ministère de la
Santé on dépend du ministère des
Solidarités et de la et de l'handicap
nous on est le prendre soin de la santé
c'est à dire qu'on est la prévention de
la santé c'est nous à domicile qui a
l'air t-on les infirmiers c'est nous qui
allons longtemps les les médecins c'est
nous qui allons promener la dame pendant
une demi-heure et qui et qui va éviter
un médicament ou une visite chez le
médecin donc oui il faudrait que les
deux ministères se réunissent et
travaillent je rajouterai un troisième
ministère c'est le ministère du Travail
qui devrait se réunir sur nos conditions
de travail sur notre pénibilité et et
sur notre statut parce qu'on n'a pas de
statut sur la retraite l'âge
c'est difficile c'est difficile mais il
faut mettre un âge
ce serait 60 ans et encore à 60 ans on
est déjà fatigué
après nous on aimerait une retraite
progressive
pour qu'on puisse partir plus tôt et
qu'on soit pas pénalisé sur le la
pension de la retraite
merci beaucoup madame Dembélé
la parole est à Madame Marie-Charlotte
Carin pour le groupe et colonie peste
merci et merci à tous les trois pour vos
interventions je vais m'adresser plus
particulièrement à vous madame l'oseille
dans les réponses que vous avez
apportées notamment sur la question de
la prévention j'entends bien évidemment
le besoin de formation le besoin
d'accompagnement notamment psychologique
face à ce que vous pouvez rencontrer
dans vos métiers au quotidien j'entends
aussi la question du statut ça a été
évoqué par mes collègues j'entends aussi
la question de l'amplitude horaire qui
est une forme de pénibilité sur le temps
long au vu des temps partiels et du
nombre de jours et de personnes que vous
voyez dans la même journée sans
forcément pouvoir l'enchaîner j'entends
aussi si on va plus loin la question de
la revalorisation salariale puisque
c'est aussi un aspect qui a un angle
mort pour les métiers du soin
moi j'aimerais beaucoup que vous nous
détailler encore les spécificités de la
pénibilité de votre métier donc
peut-être en donnant quelques exemples
que ce soit pour la pénibilité physique
pour la pénibilité psychologique et pour
la pénibilité émotionnelle puisque quand
on demande aux gens de travailler plus
longtemps il faut bien qu'on ait
conscience de ce que ça implique pour le
corps pour l'esprit et pour tout un
corps de métier qui est sous-estimé sous
valorisé aujourd'hui et qui pourtant est
un des piliers de notre société je vous
remercie
merci Madame le sec puisque ça vous
était plus particulièrement adressé
alors la pénibilité physique je vais
vous prendre un exemple
c'est le dos
les épaules les genoux les chevilles
voilà parce que vous comprenez que quand
on fait un transfert on bascule et si on
le fait mal c'est l'épaule qui prend
pardon je fais le geste en même temps
c'est c'est l'épaule qui prend et c'est
des blessures qui peuvent durer moi je
vais vous prendre le cas de ma blessure
de mon accident de travail 18 mois
le dos voilà ensuite émotionnel
c'est toute la violence qu'on peut
prendre
alors je vous parle de violence physique
parce qu'il y a des auxiliaires de vie
qui qui se prennent des coups et qui
finissent à l'hôpital avec des doigts
cassés il y a des agressions physiques
il y a des agressions sexuelles et ça on
le t on en parle pas la fin de vie comme
je vous ai parlé c'est-à-dire que on
prend tout ça donc d'une journée on peut
voir dans une journée
on se mène cette personne et en week-end
15 personnes
dans une journée donc voilà on part du
8h on rentre à 21h l'amplitude ça peut
aller jusqu'à 13h d'amplitude
donc voilà pour toute
la plus grande
[Musique]
c'est pendant le covid en fait il faut
savoir que pendant le covid tout le
monde était confiné et que à domicile on
a supprimé toutes les prises en charge à
domicile les kinés les psychologues les
orthophonistes et on n'a pas expliqué
aux personnes donc les personnes ils
avaient que nous comme lien c'est-à-dire
que nous on est allés au front on
n'avait pas de on n'était pas
prioritaire pour les masques ni rien le
premier mois donc on est allé au front
et on a pris toute leur angoisses et
nous on était angoissés aussi par la
situation et du coup on avait personne
on n'avait pas de ça de décompression il
y a quelques entreprises qui ont mis un
numéro vert mais nous on a besoin de
présentiel on en a marre des téléphones
et on n'avait pas ça donc on faisait
tous les jours je vais prendre mon cas
personnel je l'ai bien voulu le mois de
mars a été très compliqué
mes collègues sont beaucoup en
monoparental donc obligé de s'arrêter de
travailler et du coup j'ai travaillé
tout le mois de mars j'ai pas eu un jour
de repos et il m'est arrivé et c'est
pour ça que j'ai créé le collectif il
m'est arrivé un dimanche où j'ai pris
toutes les angoisses pourquoi pourquoi
on sort plus pourquoi mon seul lien
social c'était d'aller au bar son seul
lien social pourquoi je peux plus y
aller donc là c'est c'est toutes les
affaires qu'elle trouve elle elle les
balance donc là ben je me protège moi je
la laisse évacuer ces angoisses c'est
pourquoi je dois on doit
désinfecter tout en fait toutes ces
angoisses et en fait c'est tous les
jours ces angoisses là c'est tous les
jours c'est répété c'est répété et c'est
répété et en fait
on aperçoit à qui parler on est seul on
souffre d'un isolement et ça c'est une
pénibilité aussi le seul pour vous dire
on a maintenant avant on avait un peu
plus nos responsables de secteurs au
téléphone ou à l'entreprise maintenant
on a un logiciel
et on nous envoie des SMS qui qui nous
dit votre emploi du temps échanger
est-ce que vous êtes disponible on prend
plus le temps d'avoir des échanges donc
ça c'est aussi une pénibilité parce que
on est face à une robotique ensuite
l'autre pénibilité que je vous ai pas
parlé mais elle est elle est très
importante c'est le stress qui est lié
au téléphone portable qui est notre
pointeuse c'est à dire que je vais vous
prendre un cas très simple j'ai Madame
Dupont j'ai qu'une demi heure pour
enlever un petit déjeuner préparation du
repas
cette dame elle est pas encore le elle
est pas encore réveillée je vais pas la
bosquet et moi pendant ce temps j'ai tic
tac tic tac tic tac qui passe et pendant
la demi-heure mais j'ai pas fini
forcément parce qu'elle a encore un peu
plus fatigué parce que elle s'est levée
du pied gauche parce que elle a pas
envie de déjeuner parce que c'est
difficile pour elle la
déglutition et bien j'ai mon téléphone
portable au bout d'une demi-heure qui
sonne pour me dire c'est fini
mais moi j'ai pas fini avec la dame
qu'est-ce que je fais je pointe mais je
continue parce que je vais pas laisser
une personne
en plein milieu du déjeuner et du coup
ça ça
procure du stress parce que j'ai le tic
tac tic tac tic tac qui est tout le
temps là je prends ma voiture je me
dépêche parce que je suis déjà en retard
chez une autre personne risque d'accéder
de route et c'est toute la journée comme
ça voilà
merci merci Madame le sec passons à la
question suivante elle est posée par
Monsieur Frédéric cabrolier pour le
groupe rassemblement national
d'abord je suis très content qu'on
puisse parler de la pénibilité puisqu'on
n'a pas pu c'était l'article 9 du projet
de loi sur les retraites donc merci à
vous
donc la pénibilité ça repose sur le
compte de prévention
professionnelle de prévention c'est un
peu une usine à gaz aujourd'hui
puisque c'est un système de points et de
seuil mais qui est plafonné
ça vous permet parmi les trois
possibilités de partir plus tôt par
exemple aujourd'hui avant 62 ans et
demain peut-être 62 ans donc là il y a
une injustice mais qui est liée à tous
les salariés dans la santé les
auxiliaires de vie sont souvent salariés
soit parce qu'elle travaille à la DMR
soit parce qu'elles sont indépendantes
mais se font payer en chaque emploi
service et au régime complémentaire de
l'Arco quand vous partez par exemple à
62 ans faut le savoir aujourd'hui vous
avez pendant 300 les trois années qui
suivent 10 % de décote donc moi les
questions que je vais poser en 2017 il y
a eu quatre facteurs de pénibilité qui
ont été supprimés par le gouvernement
donc bon ça ressort un peu mais n'est-il
pas donc indispensable de réintégrer les
trois facteurs de pénibilité 10
ergonomique
port de charge lourdes donc ça vous
concerne posture PM pénible notamment
puisque les risques ergonomiques sont à
l'origine des troubles des troubles
musculo-squelettiques et représentent
90% des maladies professionnelles
reconnues de la veuve même de l'étude
d'impact de la réforme faut-il pas non
plus déplafonner ce C2P puisque
aujourd'hui c'est le cas et donc là
c'était plutôt quand même pour la partie
santé madame et pour les agriculteurs
moi il se trouve que j'ai rencontré la
MSA également
ça il ressort effectivement qu'il y a un
problème avec la médecine du travail
problème de service de santé il y aurait
une première visite médicale à 45 ans et
une deuxième à 61 ans est-ce que vous me
confirmez ça me paraît assez espacé ça
et est-ce qu'il faudrait pas tenir
compte donc pour tous ces métiers
pénibles des indemnités journalières
maladie ou accident suite à une maladie
ou un accident pour les exploitants et
les métiers de la santé dans le calcul
de la retraite merci
alors la parole est un monsieur Bouchut
peut-être allez
donc nous on n'a pas de compte
pénibilité c'est simple paysan n'en a
pas des salariés agricoles oui nous on
en a point donc c'est pour ça que je
refaisais une proposition en disant
travailler sur desotex pour qu'on ait
des choses qui nous permettent de partir
plus tôt je rejoins la personne qui est
avant moi
c'est pas le débat pour l'instant mais
l'âge de la retraite oui moi j'ai fait
j'avais 30 43 ans de cotisation je suis
parti à 60 ans et c'était bien
physiquement je pouvais encore la
pression était très lourdes
alors la question de l'espacement des
visites moi j'ai eu une vraie visite
dans ma carrière j'étais paysan pendant
31 ans j'ai eu une vraie visite pendant
31 ans
avec ça vous vous débrouillez comme vous
pouvez vous allez voir votre médecin
donc je suis dans une zone où il y a des
médecins donc ça va mais ça veut dire
que c'est très très compliqué donc on a
besoin réellement de travailler
là-dessus de faire des visites
obligatoires l'anticipation le travail
enfin le travail de fond qui n'a pas été
fait il faut qu'on se mette autour d'une
table que cette question des retraites
nous permettent enfin de traiter ces
questions là je suis d'accord avec vous
les questions sont très pertinentes
merci Madame les Goulet vous souhaitez
compléter
quelques éléments peut-être sur alors
effectivement la réintégration des les
quatre facteurs de pénibilité
ça me semble être
quelque chose d'important
parce que c'est facteurs-là ne sont pas
là pour rien et ont été identifiés
clairement depuis de nombreuses années
comme des facteurs importants donc à ne
pas minimiser ceci dit cela ne règlera
pas forcément la question des pénibilité
dans de nombreux métiers et donc il ne
faut pas croire que en réintégrant ces
quatre facteurs on aura réglé la
question de la pénibilité au travail
loin de là
alors ensuite sur la question du
déplafonnement des points comme je l'ai
dit dans mon propos liminaire moi je
suis très partagée sur cette question là
et même plutôt
je doute de son intérêt parce que ça
revient quand même à considérer que
finalement et bien la durée d'exposition
à ces pénibilité n'est pas grave et que
au final et bien tant qu'on peut gagner
des points on gagne ensemble mais au
final quand même c'est au détriment de
sa santé et donc ça il ne faut pas
l'oublier et donc l'idée d'un conte de
prévention qui ne fonctionnerait en
finalement habillement un peu plus les
personnes et en les incitant
éventuellement à
transiger entre leur santé et leur
départ en retraite anticipée me semble
être une question qui est largement
discutable donc voilà ça me semble être
quelque chose à revoir
et davantage travailler sur une réelle
prévention des risques professionnels
plutôt que sur ces questions là
troisième point je l'ai dit également
mais je le redis effectivement accolé
risque et
ergonomique et tout à fait étonnant et
voilà témoigne de la méconnaissance de
l'ergonomie de son projet et de ses
ambitions qui est justement d'améliorer
les conditions de travail de concevoir
un travail adaptable à la diversité des
populations et non pas de s'intéresser
voilà à des à des risques qui
deviendraient ergonomiques en eux-mêmes
et par eux-mêmes voilà merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
Petavy pour le groupe
non il y a pas de demande il y a pas de
question
très bien
alors Monsieur Gérard Russell à la
parole merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos témoignages sur les différentes
pénibilités sur la nécessaire et
intégration des critères de pénibilité
notamment dans le domaine du Caire et de
l'aide à domicile dont on sait les
rémunérations restent malheureusement
très très écrasé vous avez mille fois
raison avant de parler de retraite il
faut parler des conditions de travail
c'est une évidence mais vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure une retraite progressive
ce qui est justement la transition entre
le travail et la retraite est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
ce que vous
attendiez d'une réforme intelligente
notamment sur ce point là merci par
avance merci beaucoup
alors ce qu'on attend c'est que par
exemple une auxiliaire de vie qui est
que la médecine du travail dit qu'elle
est fatiguée et qu'elle peut plus porter
des charges qu'elle parte pour
grossitivement alors après c'est c'est à
réfléchir parce que parce que je suis
pas spécialiste non plus
mais en tout cas quand il y a un avis
médical pour pour partir plus tôt et
qu'on nous réponde pas bah non madame
vous devez continuer parce que vous avez
pas vous annuité et
voilà c'est vraiment de continuer je
voudrais rebondir sur sur monsieur
dans le maintien domicile il y a quatre
secteurs il y a la fonction publique il
y a l'associatif il y a le l'associatif
privé les entreprises privées et il y a
l'employeur employé voilà c'est il y a
pas que la DMR est voilà on est quatre
secteurs et c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
une convention collective et
qu'une seule pour
travailler sur les conditions de travail
parce qu'il faut vraiment travailler sur
les conditions de travail avant de
parler de vos têtes
oui juste quelques éléments sur cette
question de la retraite progressive
parce que il me semble que ça fait le
lien avec quelques quelque chose qui a
été déjà discuté aussi tout à l'heure la
nécessité d'anticiper et cette retraite
progressive est une manière aussi de
travailler la question de l'anticipation
me semble-t-il l'anticipation sur une
une articulation entre la vie au travail
et la vie au travail la vie
professionnelle et puis la retraite et
donc cet articulation là me semble être
intéressante et
proposer justement des voix importantes
pour un certain nombre de personnes dont
les métiers sont difficiles à tenir
jusqu'à l'âge aujourd'hui de la retraite
voir celui à venir donc travailler en
anticipation c'est aussi se donner les
moyens de cette anticipation aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a peu d'outils en tout
cas généralisé qui permettent de
réfléchir à cette anticipation et
notamment à travailler sur certains
points dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
que sont les troubles infra
pathologiques alors qu'est-ce que sont
ces trous l'infar pathologies ce ne sont
pas des pathologies comme leur nom
l'indique mais ce sont un certain nombre
de difficultés de de douleur de signaux
finalement déjà bien installés mais qui
permettent encore de faire un certain
nombre de choses notamment si en
évaluant ces en et en essayant de
repérer ces troubles informatiques et
bien aussi on les associe à l'évolution
des conditions de travail et à
l'évolution du travail et du contenu du
travail lui-même et donc travailler
notamment sur l'élaboration d'un certain
nombre d'observatoires qui permettent
justement ce travail en anticipation des
évolutions à la fois du travail de ces
conditions d'organisation de la question
de la pression temporelle de
l'intensification du travail notamment
et puis également de l'évolution de de
la santé des personnes me semble être
important justement pour
réfléchir à cette anticipation et
permettre aussi de travailler
potentiellement la question de la
retraite progressive pour un certain
nombre de personnes qui seraient
concernées par ces difficultés de santé
infra pathologique
et nous en avons terminé avec les
questions je remercie nos invités pour
leur participation à nos travaux et
avant de passer à la seconde partie de
ce débat je suspends la séance pour une
durée de trois minutes le temps
d'accueillir monsieur le ministre
la séance est reprise
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
quelques mots pour introduire ce débat
autour de la pénibilité la demande du
groupe Europe Écologie Les Verts
pardonnez-moi en tout cas demande du
groupe des écologistes moi comme ça je
suis sûr de ne pas égorger écorché
quelques chroniques que ce soit
simplement un mot pour vous dire que la
question de la pénibilité est évidemment
un volet central de la réforme des
retraites qui est en cours d'examen mais
au-delà des questions relatives au
travail et à la qualité des emplois
proposés c'est un sujet central qui
d'une part doit répondre à des attentes
nombreuses exprimées par les différents
partenaires sociaux et je crois que les
concertations que nous avons menées dans
le cadre de la préparation du projet de
loi de réforme des retraites ont permis
de trouver un certain nombre de points
d'équilibre de convergence cela ne
signifie pas qu'il y a un accord sur la
question des retraites bien loin sans
faux c'est même plutôt l'inverse mais
sur ces questions de pénibilité nous
avons pu ouvrir un certain nombre de
discussions de manière variable avec
d'une part les organisations patronales
qui avaient des attentes particulières
avec les organisations syndicales même
si de manière très schématique peut-être
même simpliste il y avait parmi il y a
parmi les organisations syndicales un
certain nombre d'organisations dès la
création du C3P et puis des C2P avait
dit
sinon leur hostilité en tout cas leur
manque de d'adhésion à ce projet
d'outils et puis d'autres qui croient
plus si je puis me permettre de
m'autoriser cette expression et qui
considère qu'au-delà des désaccords
exprimés sur les questions d'âge sur les
questions de modalités il peut y avoir
ici ou là des convergences et des
progrès c'est aussi un point central car
dès lors qu'on est dans une logique qui
consiste à travailler un peu plus
longtemps cela implique de travailler
mieux et donc de mieux prévenir les
questions de pénibilité d'usure du jour
au travail d'améliorer les conditions de
travail d'éviter l'enfermement dans les
métiers difficiles et de faciliter
l'accès aux formations et reconversions
qui sont autant de priorité à la fois
dans le cas de la réforme examinée comme
dans le reste de ma feuille de route
cette ce débat et cet échange
aujourd'hui permet d'aborder ces
questions et d'aborder peut-être
précisément pour ce qui me concerne des
dispositions nous prévoyons dans le cas
du pvfssr en matière de pénibilité
puisque c'est un article que nous
n'avons pu aborder dans l'hémicycle et
d'une certaine manière je remercie le
groupe écologiste de nous proposer ce
temps de rattrapage en tout cas de
débats supplémentaire pour évoquer ces
questions de pénibilité la première
chose que je veux souligner et qu'en
matière de pénibilité de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle notre premier
objectif est de changer d'échelle
changer d'échelle car les précédentes
réformes en matière de retraites ou de
prise en compte de la pénibilité ont
permis évidemment d'approcher le sujet
d'améliorer les choses sans jamais
totalement l'épuiser la réforme de 2010
portée par Eric verte a introduit dans
notre droit la notion de pénibilité sous
l'angle de la de la réparation c'est à
dire d'un départ anticipé au titre de
l'incapacité permanente j'y reviendrai
et la réforme de 2014 ensuite porté et
il pensait le dispositif de compte de
pénibilité très ambitieux dans son
principe c'est alors que nous parlions
de ces trois P plus difficile à mettre
en oeuvre pour les critères ergonomiques
je reviendrai aussi sur ces critères d'y
ergonomiques ce qui nous a amené en 2017
à revenir à une version qualifiée de C2P
compte professionnel de prévention nous
souhaitons donc apporter une réponse à
la fois plus en plus plus ambitieuse
plus complète et plus effective au
travers du texte que je défends devant
le Parlement depuis quelques semaines
ambitieuse car la mise en oeuvre de
cette politique s'accompagne de la
création d'un fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle qui sera dotée d'un
milliard d'euros sur le quinquennat sur
les quatre années restants c'est un
véritable changement d'échelle puisque
lorsque l'on regarde les moyens
consacrés par la branche ATMP à la
prévention de la pénibilité nous sommes
en moyenne autour de 40 millions d'euros
par an et avec un milliard sur les
quatre à cinq ans qui viennent le
changement d'échelle se perçoit aisément
au moins d'un point de vue arithmétique
notre volonté et que ce fonds de
préhension soit apporté par et donc dans
le cas du dialogue social puisque ce
sont les partenaires sociaux qui sont
principalement à la manœuvre pour la
gestion de cette branche ATMP la
deuxième caractéristique de la réponse
telle que nous la pensions en tout cas
et son caractère plus complet et c'est
la raison pour laquelle au-delà des 6
facteurs qui restent inscrits dans le
C2P nous souhaitons une approche
nouvelle avec des solutions aussi
concrètes que possible pour
permettre de prévenir l'usure et de la
réparer quand c'est nécessaire pour les
métiers les plus exposés au port de
charge lourdes aux vibrations et aux
postures pénible ce qui relève des trois
critères d’hy ergonomiques et trois
critères qui génèrent l'écrasante
majorité des troubles
musculoosquelettiques et enfin une
réponse effective car les plus grands
écueils lorsqu'on aborde ces questions
de pénibilité et de penser des
dispositifs qui en réalité sont assez
éloignés des réalités de l'entreprise
des réalités du quotidien et donc notre
objectif est d'avoir un dispositif qui
soit le plus opérationnel possible et le
plus concret dans ses résultats
quelques mots suite et pour terminer sur
la les précisions à apporter autour de
ces dispositions d'abord pour dire que
pour ce qui concerne le C2P tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui nous voulons
l'améliorer l'améliorer en levant un
certain nombre de verrou qui existe
aujourd'hui qui peut-être le rendre
moins effectif moins facile à utiliser
que ce que nous pourrions souhaiter
c'est la raison laquelle pour laquelle
nous allons abaisser plusieurs seuils
pour acquérir des droits nous allons
renforcer l'acquisition de droit pour
les salariés d'hypogly exposés et nous
allons augmenter la valeur des droits à
qui par les salariés au titre de C2P
ainsi à titre d'illustration nous allons
abaisser de 120 à 100 le nombre de nuits
travaillés par an pour obtenir des
points nous allons supprimer le plafond
de 100 points qui existe aujourd'hui et
un point de C2P qui permettait jusqu'à
présent de financer 375 euros de
formation permettra de financer pour 500
euros de formation d'où l'augmentation
de la valeur des points et je tiens
aussi à préciser que les trimestres
d'anticipation départ à la retraite
seront aussi désormais si la réforme est
adoptée bien sûr intégralement prise en
compte dans le calcul de la pension des
assurés il y a une autre nouveauté que
je veux souligner pour ce qui concerne
le C2P c'est la création d'une nouvelle
utilisation possible à la disposition
des travailleurs ayant un C2P des points
si accumulés avec la création d'un congé
de reconversion comme nouvelle
utilisation du compte pour mettre fin à
l'enfermement des métiers difficiles
j'ai pu écouter une partie des
intervenants précédents je pense
notamment à Madame Deloulay qui comme
ergonome auprès du CNAM si j'ai bien
noté et être souligné l'importance qu'il
y a d'éviter l'enfermement dans des
métiers pénibles de façon à permettre
aussi les reconversions de permettre de
nouveaux parcours professionnels et
l'orientation vers des métiers moins
exposés à l'usure professionnelle
l'objectif est que les travailleurs qui
ont recours à cette nouvelle modalité de
congé de reconversion puisse bénéficier
d'un congé de reconversion
professionnelle rémunéré à 100% et avec
une formation tout aussi tout aussi
financée
la deuxième chose que nous allons faire
concerne donc les critères ergonomiques
l'objectif est de faciliter la
prévention et la réparation de
l'exposition à la pénibilité et ce que
nous proposons c'est que la branche ATMP
qui dispose de statistiques et d'outils
extrêmement nombreux je pense
au taux de la prévalence des maladies
professionnelles au taux
d'accidentologie pour les accidents du
travail mais aussi à l'enquête summer
sur les conditions de travail puis
signifier aux branches professionnelles
la liste des métiers par branche qui
sont par principe par hypothèse et
appuyer sur ces éléments statistiques
les métiers les plus exposés à ce risque
d'usure professionnelle et en
particulier ces trois critères dit
ergonomiques les branches seront ensuite
tenues négocier un accord de prévention
co-financé par le fond que j'ai évoqué
précédemment et de mettre en oeuvre cet
accord de prévention pour justement
mettre l'accent sur la prévention de
l'usure et éviter un maximum
d'expositions les salariés des métiers
ainsi identifiés seront aussi
l'objet d'un suivi médical spécifique
avec notamment une première visite
médicale obligatoire à mi carrière une
dernière obligatoire à 61 ans pour être
tout à fait sûr que celles et ceux qui
malheureusement n'auraient pas été
suffisamment protégé par la prévention
puisse bénéficier de départ anticiper et
dans l'intervalle chaque branche devra
arrêter le rythme des visites et du
suivi médical j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
les questions relatives au départ en
retraite pour incapacité permanente
c'est un départ qui est possible deux
ans avant l'âge légal avec la
possibilité d'un départ à taux plein à
62 ans que nous maintenons et nous
voulons simplifier l'accès à la fois en
assouplissant fortement les conditions
pour les salariés ayant un taux
d'incapacité compris entre 10 et 20% et
en rendant automatique le droit à des
parents anticipé pour les salariés qui
se voient reconnaître un taux
d'incapacité supérieure à 20%
je fais juste une parenthèse avant de
conclure pour dire que
c'est de se départ anticiper sur avis
médical amène de ma part de deux
observations la première observation
c'est qu'il y a là un point de désaccord
avec un certain nombre de partenaires
sociaux en particulier les organisations
syndicales que j'ai qualifiées que tout
à l'heure comme étant assez convaincu
par l'utilité du C2P ce n'est pas le cas
de toutes qui auraient souhaité préférée
que le départ anticipé soit automatique
pour les travailleurs qui exercent un
des métiers listés par la branche à TMP
nous ne partageons pas ce point de vue
pour une seule raison ou en tout cas
pour l'explication suivante nous
considérons que le départ anticipé est
une réparation lorsque l'usure n'a pas
pu être prévenu
mais nous considérons important la vie
médicale individuelle car derrière les
codes métiers derrière la définition des
métiers qui sont concernés la réalité
des conditions d'exposition à l'usure
professionnelle peut-être très
différente je me prends que deux
exemples le premier concerne un métier
qui est par définition pénible s'agit
par exemple des aides-soignants dans les
EHPAD c'est un métier pénible tout le
monde le reconnaîtra facilement mais
l'exposition la pénibilité n'est
évidemment pas la même selon que les pas
des intégralement équipé de ride de
Level malade d'assistance mécanique pour
la manipulation des patients ou si au
contraire l'intégralité des
manipulations doivent être faites par
les individus ça reste un métier pénible
mais avec deux conditions d'exercices
qui sont différentes et de la même
manière vous pouvez l'être menuisier
avec un même code métier mais exercer
sur des chantiers à l'extérieur exposé à
des températures très variables ou à
l'inverse d'exercer dans un lieu clos
parfois avec une température régulée et
une des machines à commande numérique
avec le même code métier vous n'aurez
pas les mêmes niveaux d'exposition
à la pénibilité d'où pour nous
l'importance du renvoi un aspect plus
relevant du suivi médical individuel
enfin je termine en disant que sur cette
réforme des retraites il y a la volonté
de mieux prendre en compte la pénibilité
et que je le vois comme un jalon comme
une étape supplémentaire une étape qui
vient après les questions relatives à la
santé au travail notamment à l'accord
interprofessionnel dans ce domaine qui a
donné lieu à une loi adoptée à l'été
2021 revoyant profondément les missions
des services de santé au travail et
concrétisant aussi des avancées autour
de la visite de mie carrière mais aussi
une étape avant d'autres travaux sur la
qualité de vie et les conditions de vie
au travail c'est là la deuxième remarque
que je voulais faire après celle sur le
suivi médical et qui fait l'objet qui
peut faire l'objet d'un désaccord c'est
le fait qu'en réalité les départs
anticipés au titre de la réparation
puisque c'est ce terme qui est utilisé
depuis la loi 2010 ne sont pas
totalement satisfaisants et c'est un
droit il faut le protéger il faut en
garantir l'accès facilité et en
simplifier l'accès mais de manière plus
structurelle plus fondamentale je pense
que nous avons tous en commun la volonté
de mieux protéger et travailleurs de
l'exposition à l'usure et à la
pénibilité pour que chacun puisse aller
jusqu'à l'âge légal de départ quel que
soit la vie qu'on a sur le niveau
pertinent de l'âge légal en bonne santé
et prendre sa retraite à l'âge légal en
bonne santé plutôt que de considérer
comme satisfaisant des départs anticipés
mais avec une santé altérée par
l'exposition à l'usure je pense que
c'est là la principale justification le
principal intérêt de tout ce que nous
pourrons faire autour de la prévention
voilà la présidence parce que je
pourrais dire en ouverture de ce débat
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre et
nous en venant à la série des questions
elles seront de deux minutes les
réponses de 2 minutes également et je
vous rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de droit
de réplique la parole pour le groupe
écolo nu-petit à Madame Sophie tailler
polian
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces éléments
nous n'avons certes pas eu le temps
formellement de débat de l'article 9
mais nous avons quand même au cours des
débats qui ont eu lieu ces dernières
semaines beaucoup abordées les questions
de pénibilité même si nous avons
souhaité au groupe écologiste aller plus
plus à fond et se débat et se déballe le
permet petitement parce que ce sera très
court vous évoquiez le fait que la
politique menait était je dirais
ambitieuse nous n'avons pas du tout la
même vision des choses pour nous vos
propositions ne sont que des mesures
d'adaptation qui sont si faibles au
regard de ce qui est demandé aux
salariés de ce pays c'est-à-dire
travailler deux ans de plus et
d'ailleurs dans les concertations avec
les organisations syndicales si je ne
m'abuse toutes demandées à ce que la
question de l'amélioration des
conditions de travail l'amélioration de
la prévention au travail était un
préalable à toute autre discussion sur
les questions du
des retraites et nous considérons que le
départ anticipé des salariés finalement
devraient éviter l'altération de la
santé et pas forcément venir réparer une
santé altérée et donc une retraite qui
ne peut pas être prise avec toute la
toutes les possibilités que l'on peut
avoir pour une retraite quand on est en
très bonne santé donc ouais la politique
du ministère du Travail pour développer
redévelopper la médecine du travail
remettre un petit peu de d'allant et de
dynamisme et d'essayer de convaincre des
étudiants de devenir médecin du travail
nous en manquons où est aussi la
politique de prévention primaire où est
la grande politique pour faire en sorte
que dans toutes les entreprises se
développent la culture de prévention où
est la politique pour éviter finalement
que ce compte de professionnels de
prévention n'en soit plus un puisque
finalement comment peut-on parler d'un
conte de prévention quand on déplaphone
les seuils c'est-à-dire que finalement
et bien l'altération est possible
jusqu'au ciel jusqu'au jusqu'au plus
haut pour avoir un nombre de points où
est la politique également pour limiter
la pénibilité et pour prendre en compte
la pénibilité des femmes qui ne sont
toujours pas au cœur du dispositif du
C2P et nous ne voyons pas aucunement
comment elle peut être pris en compte
par vos propositions merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci merci Madame la député je
m'attendais pas à ce que vous me
féliciter en réalité donc je ne suis pas
surpris mais je ne partage pas tout de
vos propos vous le pensez bien je pense
que tout ne peut pas être dans la loi
que que je porte en matière de réforme
des retraites et de pénibilité d'abord
parce que sur la question de la
pénibilité une chose que l'on fait dans
la loi je reviens pas sur ce que j'ai
dit je pense que ce sont des
améliorations je pense aussi que c'est
une étape et que nous aurons d'autres
étapes notamment un autre texte de loi
plus ordinaire
permettant d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de chantier je pense aussi que la
revalorisation est le fait de redonner
de l'attractivité à la médecine du
travail ne passera pas par des lois mais
plutôt par des plans sectorielles que
devant travailler avec mon collègue
ministre de la santé parce que la
désinfection que l'on peut constater
parfois pour ces services de santé au
travail n'est pas nouvelle et apporte
des réponses très certainement à
l'échelle de toute une filière je
précise cependant que la loi santé au
travail de 2021 nous donne quelques
outils notamment je pense à un en
particulier qui est la possibilité
d'avoir des infirmiers des infirmières
en pratique avancées pour un certain
nombre d'actes ou l'autorité des
médecins comme c'est le cas lorsqu'on
parle d'IPA et le décret d'application
de cette disposition a été publiée au
tout début de l'année puisque le hasard
du calendrier fait qu'il a été publié au
Journal officiel le 1er janvier dernier
sur un dernier point vous avez évoqué
sur lequel je viens rapidement mais mais
qui fait peut-être le noeud du désaccord
je considère que des plafonner le C2P
comme nous le faisons mais absolument
pas contradictoire avec la politique de
prévention je pense que et je l'ai dit
la politique prévention pour moi et la
clé absolue en matière de pénibilité
c'est là qu'on doit mettre tous les
efforts et c'est là qu'on doit
concentrer l'essentiel de notre énergie
avec un objectif qui est
particulièrement utopiste parce que il
est à long terme il ne peut pas être
parfait qui est d'éviter justement que
les salariés soient exposés soient
contraint ou conduit à des départs si
petites de la réparation mais bien
permettre et les bienfaits les
orientations et la prévention par contre
des plafonnés c'est donner aux salariés
qui sont qui ont été exposés la
possibilité d'avoir autant de points que
leur situation le justifie et parce que
derrière le nombre de points accumulés
et des plafonnés il y a beaucoup plus
d'usages possibles tant en termes de
départ anticipé que de financement de
cette nouvelle utilisation qu'on propose
autour du congé de reconversion
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre d'arriville pour le
groupe GDR nus
merci maintenant la présidente monsieur
le ministre
je me concentrer sur le sujet de de la
pénibilité
en vous répétant quand même au début de
ce propos que nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire que le texte que vous avez
mis sur la table soit retiré compte tenu
de l'opposition massive qu'il suscite et
de son caractère régressif du point de
vue social et d'ailleurs il y a une
forme d'aveu puisque vous avez été
contraint vous-même de mettre dans ce
texte des mesures qu'on pourrait
qualifier je sais pas d'accompagnement
mais qui évidemment ne font pas du tout
la balance et d'ailleurs peut-on faire
la balance quand on demande aux gens de
travailler deux ans de plus bon donc
parmi ces mesures il y a des sujets
autour de la pénibilité moi je voudrais
vous poser au moins deux questions la
première est-ce que
il serait pas utile de faire un vrai
bilan du C2P je rappelle que la Cour des
comptes a rendu un rapport en fin 2022
où il est écrit qu'il était voué un
exercice qu'un effet réduit sans impact
sur la prévention
or le diagnostic que nous faisons est
assez sévère à l'égard de ce C2P et de
ses de ses effets donc vous continuez
d'investir dans ce dispositif mais en
réalité on sait très bien qu'il ne croit
pas répondre aux enjeux et avec une
logique de médicalisation que vous avez
exposé tout à l'heure qui va à
l'encontre un peu de la logique de droit
collectif que nous défendons deuxième
aspect sur l'invalidité il me semble
qu'il doit y avoir des discussions en
cours sur ce sujet là vous savez que
l'invalidité c'est quand même un coup
près qui tombe et qui n'est pas
satisfaisant pour celles et ceux qui qui
sont concernés ou en êtes-vous de ce
point de vue là ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des renseignements
complémentaires enfin sur le fond
d'investissement monsieur le ministre il
y a un problème sur la philosophie même
de la branche ATMP
puisqu'elle n'est pas faite pour ça et
que en réalité là il y a des fonds qui
vont
intervenir là où ce qui est en jeu c'est
la responsabilité des entreprises
donc je suis un peu étonné par ce
dispositif que vous mettez en place il a
philosophie qui le
qui le sous-tend
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente je m'en viens pas sur la
production puisque c'est du rappel d'un
désaccord mais simplement peut-être dire
à Monsieur le Député d'arriville que le
rapport de la Cour des comptes que vous
évoquez et justement une des raisons des
modifications que nous apportons au C2P
à la fois pour qu'ils puissent se
déployer plus facilement que son intérêt
soit plus fort et le fait que son
intérêt soit plus fort envoie à la fois
la question de déplophone du
déplafonnement que j'ai évoqué il y a un
instant à la question de l'augmentation
de la valeur des points en tout cas de
la valeur en termes de formation de
chacun des points pour permettre l'accès
à des parcours qui soit plus fort par
rapport à ce qui se fait aujourd'hui par
la meilleure prise en compte de la
polyexposition c'est un des points que
j'ai évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
mais qui compte tout comme par
l'abaissement des seuils pour le rendre
plus facile à mettre en oeuvre parce que
je comprends bien évidemment que si un
C2P est ouvert par un salarié et que les
critères pourra obtenir des points sont
beaucoup trop restrictif ça perdent de
l'intérêt même à l'ouvrir et donc c'est
vraiment ce sens là qu'on recherchons et
c'est la même chose avec cette nouvelle
utilisation que nous prévoyons autour de
la reconversion sur la question de ce
que vous avez appelé la médicalisation
et son
caractère antagoniste avec la logique de
droit collectif je crois aux droits
collectif pour ce qui concerne la
prévention d'où le renvoi aux branche et
au dialogue social par contre je reste
convaincu j'ai essayé de l'expliquer
tout à l'heure que la logique de
réparation est notamment la décision de
d'un départ anticipé doit rester appuyé
sur un suivi médical individuel pour
justement tenir compte de la réalité de
l'exposition à tel ou telle facteur de
pénibilité et à des conditions de
travail particulièrement
particulièrement pénibles sur la
question de l'invalidité je vous
reviendrai parce que je n'ai pas assez
d'éléments pour vous répondre à cet
instant donc je préfère ne pas vous dire
de bêtises et sur la question du
financement pour peut-être justifier la
logique et la nôtre nous considérons que
la branche MP a une situation
aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui pour les
années qui viennent qui amène cette
branche à connaître un résultat
excédentaire assez marqué une fois prise
en compte les retraitements au titre des
déclarations c'est un flux dans la
branche maladie qui est à peu près de 1
milliard un milliard de par an selon les
exercices budgétaires et les prévisions
qui sont les notes disent qu'une fois ce
retraitement effectué l'excédent est à 3
milliards 3 par an en 2025 ce qui
justifie un financement de dépenses
qu'on pourrait qualifier de dépenses
actives
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Stéphane Lenormand pour le
groupe
merci monsieur le ministre de cet
échange c'est vrai qu'on aurait aimé
avoir eu plus de temps pour discuter
d'un sujet qui est au combien important
donc j'essaierai de faire cours et de
concentrer sur le compte professionnel
de prévention donc qui dans sa mutation
a perdu quatre critères de pénibilité
j'aimerais avoir un peu votre avis sur
quelques propositions qui ont été faites
par notre groupe et d'autres la première
c'est la réintégration des trois
critères ergonomiques au sein du C2P et
vient naturellement un mécanisme
issu du dialogue social et qui pourrait
s'appuyer sur la carte graphie des
métiers par exemple quel est votre avis
là-dessus que pensez-vous de l'idée de
bonifier votre texte et de maintenir les
possibilités de départ à 60 ans départ
anticipé à 60 ans au titre de cette de
ce C2P pardon puisqu'on a quand même à
faire ici à des gens qui seront cassés
par la pénibilité des métiers qu'ils
auront à exercer quel est votre avis
aussi sur finalement une extension de ce
C2P par exemple
contractuels de la fonction publique qui
ont sont exclus puisque ce procédé est
essentiellement destiné au privé enfin
que pensez-vous d'élargir les
orientations du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle à l'ensemble des 10
facteurs de risques professionnels et
non pas seulement aux trois critères
ergonomiques ce sont des questions dans
j'aimerais avoir votre avis et enfin
j'aimerais revenir aussi un peu comme le
collègue Daredevil sur ce fond
d'investissement de la prévention et de
l'usure professionnelle bon c'est vrai
que en termes d'échelle c'est un montant
important mais l'utilisation de de ces
fonds m'interpelle un peu et j'aimerais
peut-être que non pas vous me donniez
une déclinaison précise sur les 5 années
à venir mais voir comment le
gouvernement voit l'utilisation de de
ces crédits de ces fonds à destination
des objectifs pour lesquels ils sont
destinés merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup de questions donc pardon pour
le style télégraphique mais si je les
fais par leurs anverses en ce qui
concerne le fond d'investissement de
deux éléments de réponse le 1er c'est
que pour ce qui concerne les dépenses
éligibles nous sommes très ouverts même
à dialogue social et à la nature des
accords de prévention et ouvert aussi
pour le financement temps d'équipement
notamment d'équipements ergonomique qui
peuvent être utiles pour assurer une
vraie prévention de l'usure et de la
pénibilité que le financement de
formation le financement d'information
collective ou encore de parcours de
reconversion donc la liste n'est pas
définitivement arrêtée à descend puisque
nous ne pouvons pas renvoyer au dialogue
social de branche la définition des
accords de prévention et totalement
enfermé la liste des actions qui
relèveraient de ces accords ainsi
co-financés par le fonds
d'investissement nous préférons les
centrer sur les trois critères
ergonomiques notamment parce que ça
tombe des six autres critères nous
paraissent plus difficiles à appeler en
terme d'action de prévention le travail
de nuit par exemple ou le travail en 38
et parfois une contrainte en termes
organisation des entreprises mais qui
peut difficilement faire l'objet d'un
accord de prévention de financement
d'action au titre de désaccord de
prévention sur l'extension du C2P aux
agents contractuels fonction publique
c'est une piste que nous n'avons pas
retenue à ce stade qui a fait l'objet de
quelques échanges et de discussions mais
nous avons considéré que pour la
fonction publique il était plus
important d'avoir des outils spécifiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
fonction publique est Astra mobilise et
que nous mettrons en place les
dispositions nécessaires pour cela y
compris des spécifiques financiers
raison pour laquelle le projet de loi
tel que je vous les présenter il y a
quelques jours prévois la création d'un
fond de prévention de la pénibilité pour
les métiers du soin de l'afph comme de
l'afpt pour couvrir les différents
statuts à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros par an et enfin raison pour
laquelle une discussion sera ouverte ou
peut-être a déjà été ouverte pardon pour
la précision entre mes collègues en
charge des collectivités de la fonction
publique d'une part et les représentants
des associations d'élus locaux d'autre
part puisque dans le cadre de la liberté
de gestion d'administration il est
important de voir comment de pouvoir
avancer sur la pénibilité
et enfin dernier point pardon parce que
c'est un peu long sur la réintégration
des trois critères ergonomiques nous
considérons que le décompte individuel
et presque quotidien des de l'exposition
aux postures pénible aux charges lourdes
ou vibrations est impossible
matériellement cela avait été vu en 2017
lorsqu'on est passé du c-3p au C2P c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
une autre façon de traiter ces trois
critères par les accords de prévention
et le suivi médical renforcé
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Madame astrip à nous y en bouffer merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre pour faire référence au rapport
de la Cour des comptes auxquels le
collègue d'arrivy le 6 que le collègue
dériville évoquait il y avait aussi une
critique sur la fin du principe de
pollueur payeur qui est
institué dans 2014 qui avait été levé en
2017 je voulais savoir si dans ce fond
qui était mis en place de l'ordre de 200
millions d'euros par an on reprenait ce
principe de polo européen parce que
c'est effectivement très puissant pour
lancer aussi les bonnes incitations aux
entreprises on l'a vu notamment dans la
capacité aux États-Unis de réduire
massivement les accidents du travail en
1980 dans les années 90 comme la relevé
l'économiste hknazi sur la question de
des critères ergonomiques donc je
comprends et j'entends la difficulté
d'intégrer les critères ces critères ces
trois critères dans le compte pénibilité
mais il y a quand même des professions
qui sont présumées pénible vers un
déménageurs il va porter des charges
lourdes
voilà quelqu'un qui est plombier
canalisateur ça a été d'ailleurs dit par
la patronne de Veolia elle-même il est
confronté aussi à des critères
ergonomiques qui qui font partie qui
sont inhérentes à ce qu'il fait tous les
jours quand bien même ça ne peut pas
être mesuré tous les jours donc j'ai
j'ai franchement du mal à comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
abandonner considérer dans cette liste
des métiers présumés pénibles des
métiers présumés pénibles à forte
conditions voilà
ergonomiques et enfin est-ce que vous
avez dans vos services fait un
croisement entre carrière présumée
pénible et ceux qui commencent tôt avant
20 ans pour savoir si il y a 100% de
croisement 50% de croisement ou est-ce
que voilà savoir aussi si on parle
finalement des mêmes des mêmes personnes
et des mêmes catégories
socioprofessionnelles merci monsieur le
ministre
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
souhaitons pas remettre en place les
cotisations pénibilité qui existaient
jusqu'en 2017 qui va un effet de bord
sur le coup du travail mais le
financement du fond le fait de financer
le fond de prévention d'investissement
dans la prévention sur la branche à TMP
renvoie aux modalités de financement de
la branche qui elle-même sont inscrites
dans ce principe de pollue rpailleurs
puisque il y a des majorations de taux
notamment en fonction de
l'accidentologie ou de la prévalence de
maladies professionnelles et donc on
retrouve cette esprit dans le cadre du
financement général de la branche à TNT
c'est la branche à TMP qui est amenée à
financer le fond que nous avons ainsi
que nous vous proposons ainsi de créer
sur les critères ergonomiques et un
certain nombre de profession qui de
facto sont connus pour être des
professions pénibles quoi qu'il en soit
parce qu'il n'y a pas de nécessairement
de différence d'exposition effective à
des conditions de pénibilité
contrairement aux exemples que je citais
tout à l'heure mais forcément un
caractère simpliste parce que c'est le
rôle des exemples les branches
professionnels pourront dist un certain
nombre de professions comme relevant
d'une forme de pénibilité avérée et
acquise beaucoup plus souplement et
beaucoup plus facilement que d'autres
mais on ne veut pas trop anticiper sur
ce dialogue de bronche considérant que
si on fait confiance au bronches pour
des vitaminer les accords de prévention
et la nature des réponses apportées en
termes de prévention et de réparation il
faut leur laisser aussi le temps de
discuter autour de cela et enfin sur le
croisement des carrières longues et des
critères de pénibilité il n'y a pas de
lien statistiques entre ceux qui
bénéficient ou bénéficieraient d'un
départ anticipé pour carrière longue et
ceux qui sont exposés à la pénibilité ce
ne sont pas les mêmes publics d'abord
parce qu'un certain nombre de carrières
longues sont réalisés dans des métiers
qui par définition ne sont pas aussi
pénibles que d'autres et puis nous avons
statistiquement beaucoup de personnes
qui sont éligibles un départ anticipées
pour carrière longue pour avoir commencé
tôt parfois dans des métiers pénibles
mais dont l'évolution professionnelle a
été telle ensuite qu'il leur carrière et
parfois ils atteignent rapidement à
l'occasion de leur carrière des
positions qui ne sont plus considérées
comme pénibles et d'ailleurs c'est très
statistique et un peu un peu froid comme
chiffres mais quand on regarde
l'espérance de vie à la retraite nous
sommes en moyenne sur 24 ans en France
et lorsqu'on regarde l'espérance de vie
à la retraite des personnes qui
bénéficient de dispositif carrière
longue on est plutôt autour de 25 ans et
demi 26 ans ce qui correspond à la durée
des départs anticipés ce qui signifie
que l'espérance de vie globale et et la
même puisque cette différence s'exprime
par le départ de
merci monsieur le ministre le temps file
pour le gros rassemblement national la
parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
cabronnier bien merci Monsieur le
Ministre mon réitère notre position à
votre réforme des retraites du fait de
recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans par
contre sur cet article 9 et tout ce qui
concerne la pénibilité il y a beaucoup
de choses qui nous semblent aller dans
le bon sens mais il reste quelques
injustices alors j'ai noté dans ce que
vous avez la création d'un congé de
reconversion rémunéré à 100% et des
droits à la formation avec 500 euros de
droit à la formation bon c'est quelque
chose quand on a visité ensemble
l'entreprise Coulon à Albi qui nous
avait été formulés par les seniors que
nous avons rencontrés donc ça ça va dans
le bon sens ensuite vous avez parlé de
tout ce qui est incapacité et vous
parlez d'un départ anticipé à 62 ans si
j'ai bien compris ou un peu avant bon là
il y a quand même une injustice je l'ai
formulé tout à l'heure c'est qu'en tout
cas pour les salariés dans le régime
complémentaire Arco quand on part avant
63 ans il y a une décote de 10% pendant
3 ans
donc que pouvez-vous dire par rapport à
ce problème et enfin j'ai peut-être pas
très bien suivi mais sur le passage à
temps partiel au travers du C2P qui
donnerait des droits supplémentaires
pour passer au temps partiel est-ce que
vous pouvez alors c'est quelque chose
également que les transports Coulombs
Albi nous avaient fortement dont il nous
avait fortement parlé est-ce que vous
pouvez expliciter nous en dire un peu
plus là dessus merci merci monsieur le
ministre
peut-être trois précisions la première
concerne la question de la financement
de la formation la mesure que nous
proposons et de passer la valeur du
point de 375 à 500 euros donc ce n'est
pas 500 euros au global c'est 500 euros
par point consacré au financement de la
formation et de ces formations qui
permettent qui permettent un
reclassement c'est d'ailleurs dans cette
logique là qu'on est sur une idée des
plafonnement et c'est avec cette même
logique que nous sommes sur la volonté
d'accompagner des congés de reconversion
de manière plus globale sur la question
du temps partiel on passe de trois mois
de temps partiel payé à taux plein à
quatre mois pour 10 points et donc avec
10 points de C2P vous pouvez faire
valoir le passage à temps partiel
aujourd'hui pendant trois mois demain ça
sera pendant 4 mois ce qui signifie que
avec 30 points vous devrez avoir un
temps partiel pendant un an avant votre
départ à la retraite alors
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait en avoir 40
c'est aussi une façon à défaut
d'abaisser les seuils d'acquisition des
points de faciliter ou de libérer les
conditions d'utilisation de ces points
là et enfin le dernier point que vous
avez évoqué concerne la question de la
décote dans le cadre des régimes
complémentaires et notamment de la jrco
c'est un relève pas de l'État mais de la
corne nationale interprofessionnelle
entre les partenaires sociaux et au-delà
de cet exemple que vous avez cité il y a
un certain nombre de dispositions nous
mettons que nous proposons de mettre en
oeuvre avec la loi pour le régime
général qui feront certainement mais je
ne veux pas m'avancer à la place des
partenaires sociaux l'objet de
discussion dans le cadre de la
gouvernance des régimes complémentaires
par exemple nous voulons en sorte du
champ de la pénibilité mais nous voulons
rendre contributif le cumul en plein
retraite et donc le cumulant pour la
retraite soit créateur de droit il sera
il reviendra en partenaire sociaux si le
souhaitent de se saisir de se déballer
pour faire en sorte que le caractère
contributif du cumul emploi retraite ne
soit pas réservé au sol régime général
mais bien prévu aussi pour les régimes
complémentaires et je le dis pour
l'ensemble des complémentaires et on est
dans la même logique pour ce que vous
avez aucun matière de décote et de
capacité à partir de prendre en capacité
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Saintoul pour le
groupe elle est finups merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre le
tableau de sinistralité des accidents du
travail de 2019 que j'ai sous les yeux
est absolument sans équivoque les
accidents du travail graves et mortel
augmente constamment avec l'âge les
chiffres de fréquence des accidents
mortels sont les suivants ils sont en
moyenne de 20,5 entre 15 et 19 ans ils
sont de 15 Entre 20 et 29 ils sont de 7
avec donc une légère baisse qui signale
en réalité la vulnérabilité particulière
des apprentis entre 30 et 39 ans ils
sont de 8,8 entre 40 et 49 ans de 19,2
entre 50 et 59 ans de 39,3 il passe donc
au dessus de la moyenne et entre 60 et à
partir de 60 ans ils sont de 54,2 dès
lors relever l'âge du départ à la
retraite c'est indubitablement exposer
les personnes à un risque encore accru
de mourir au travail qui a-t-il dans
votre réforme qui réponde à cela
merci Monsieur Miss vous avez la parole
en réalité monsieur le député les
chiffres que vous donnez sont juste
quand on les lis en première lecture
mais vous avez rappelé vous avez bien
fait la borne de temps de 2019 hors 2019
correspond à l'année d'une jurisprudence
de la grande cassation qui a amené les
indicateurs statistiques de l'État à
intégrer dans les accidents du travail
mortel sur le travail les malaises et
quand on regarde les chiffres de manière
plus précise et ça explique d'ailleurs
le pic d'accident du travail qu'on
s'attend en 2019 puis après il y a une
décrue en 2020 du fait de la rédactivité
et on retrouve un niveau moyen sur 21 et
22 mais quand on regarde les chiffres
dans le détail on s'aperçoit que la
fréquence des accidents du travail
diminue avec l'âge par contre la
fréquence des malaises au travail et ça
s'explique aussi par des conditions de
santé augmentent avec l'âge et donc
derrière la lecture que je répète juste
des chiffres bruts que vous avez faites
il y a des caractéristiques qui sont un
peu différentes du fait de l'intégration
depuis 2019 et par jurisprudence des
malaises dans
des accidents mortels une fois que j'ai
dit cela ce qui est très frappant dans
les accidents du travail mortel et
graves et j'ai demandé depuis ma prise
de fonction à être prévenu
systématiquement de chaque accident
mortel sur lieu de travail à l'exception
des accidents de parcours entre le
domicile et le travail ce qui est
frappant c'est que les deux
caractéristiques que l'on retrouve de
manière systématique ou presque relève
de la du caractère récent d’intégration
de l'entreprise ou du lieu de travail et
donc on retrouve pas seulement les
apprentis comme vous l'avez dit mais de
nouveaux embaucher quel que soit leur
âge des salariés intérimaires et des
salariés détachés et la deuxième
caractéristique mais quand elle est plus
spontanément si je puis dire plus
facilement dans le régime agricole
relève de l'isolement du travailleur au
moment où intervient un accident et
c'est sur ces aspects là que je souhaite
travailler j'ai évoqué un projet de loi
qui vient ça sera un vecteur mais
au-delà de ça nous avons un plan santé
au travail dont le quatrième axe de
mémoire est consacre aux accidents
gravés mortels et c'est sur ce quatrième
axe que j'ai demandé depuis le mois de
décembre au service du ministère du
Travail de se mobiliser avec les
accidents mortels en tête parce que 650
par an c'est beaucoup c'est trop sans
compter les accidents de parcours mais
en plus des accidents mortels vous avez
9600 accidents qui se traduisent par un
taux d'incapacité permanent pour les
salariés et se dire que 10000 personnes
sont marquées à vie par un accident de
travail relève peut-être d'un chiffre
encore plus inquiétant que les centaines
de morts qui sont tout aussi inacceptes
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Stéphane Viry pour le groupe
les républicains
merci Madame la présente monsieur
meunier je vous avais répondu à mes
collègues sur des questions qui me
taraudaient sur les accidents de travail
car vous mortels sur la feuille de route
qui pourrait être à la mode pour les
diminuer pour réparer intégralement les
victimes en fait le débat qui nous anime
aujourd'hui sur cette question du droit
à la retraite anticipée pour pénibilité
donc basé sur la capacité physique de
travail
et en fait en lien direct avec avec la
question du travail et vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure des points de désaccord
ou en tout cas des vues divergentes sur
d'une part l'exposition à la pénibilité
et également sur la pénibilité en soi
elle a été définie également en 2010
vous l'avez dit l'exposition ou
plusieurs facteurs moi je sens néanmoins
de notre société une évolution est-ce
qu'on évoque désormais des conditions de
travail ou des conditions du travail et
pour avoir écouté tout à l'heure les
témoins qui ont été invités à s'exprimer
à la requête de nos collègues de
l'écologie on voit bien que ce qui nous
anime au-delà de mesures techniques à
laquelle vous répondez c'est le rapport
que l'on doit avoir sur sur le travail
la santé au travail mais plus
généralement le lien ne subordination à
l'égard d'un employeur dans un schéma on
a évoqué tout à l'heure en tout cas
c'est pas maligne la question de la
soutenabilité au travail moi je me suis
mise je voudrais évoquer évoquer cette
question
cette question elle est pour moi elle
est centrale dès lors qu'on a
effectivement une difficulté à admettre
qu'on peut avoir des difficultés en lien
avec son travail qu'on cherche à régler
par de la prévention ou par des éléments
tenant compte de l'usure professionnelle
mais on sait très bien qu'il faut tenir
le coup lorsqu'on bosse on s'était bien
qu'il faut résister à l'effort qu'il
faut leur durer et ce que je peux
constater c'est que votre projet loi
elle était il applique des mesures
techniques pour tenter de combler
peut-être des carences mais qu'en
réalité une définit pas concrètement à
nouveau souffle par rapport à la
pénibilité une nouvelle définition
légale c'est un regret que j'ai moi ma
question elle est petite en lien celle
du collègue est-ce que vous entendez
mettre des critères de données
psychiques ou de santé de santé mentale
sur les critères qui existent des d'ores
et déjà en matière de en matière de
pénibilité merci monsieur le ministre
sur la question du travail en général je
pense que à la fois un débat qui est
passionnant mais qui ne trouve pas
forcément de réponse toujours dans des
dispositions législatives c'est aussi la
place que l'on donne au travail dans une
société dans une vie et les discussions
qui sont en cours dans le cadre des
acides du travail sur ces sujets là son
passionnantes pour cela mais difficile
aussi pour cela aussi c'est à dire la
difficulté à passer d'un constat d'un
énoncé de principe des dispositions qui
peuvent avoir un caractère très
technique mais qui sont nécessaires pour
véritablement changer les choses ou les
orienter on a ce travail à faire et bon
espoir qu'un certain nombre de ces
dispositions et de ses propositions
puissent trouver place dans les débats
que nous aurons au printemps et elle
était pour faire en sorte que ces
questions relatives à la qualité aux
conditions de vie au travail puisse être
pleinement abordé d'ailleurs
en même temps que les conditions de
qualité et de vie au travail des
questions de démocratie au travail dans
un environnement qui a changé et qui se
caractérise souvent par un éclatement
des lieux de travail avec le recours au
télétravail ou à des tiers-lieux ce qui
nécessite aussi de changer la
possibilité d'avoir recours à des
représentants syndicaux et donc à des
instances de représentation sur la
question des risques psychosociaux
puisque ce que vous avez abordé en
matière d'incapacité d'abord un point
pour dire que
la part des départs pour incapacité lié
à une situation
de difficulté de santé mentale augmente
progressivement et qu'un certain nombre
de d'éléments notamment de jurisprudence
permet permettre de la prendre plus
facilement en compte la difficulté qu'on
a aujourd'hui tient à une difficulté de
quantification et finalement
d'objectivation de ce qui enlève des
risques psychosociaux pour déterminer un
départ et donc aujourd'hui je crois que
nous ne sommes pas en capacité faute de
consensus sur ces sujets là et de
consensus méthodologique d'avoir des
grilles permettant de faire des risques
psychosociaux des critères de pénibilité
au départ anticipé qui soit parfaitement
mesurable et appliqué de manière un peu
collective je fais un lien avec les
départs pour incapacité j'ai dit tout à
l'heure nous allions les faciliter les
facilités c'est faire en sorte que les
salariés qui ont un taux d'incapacité de
plus de 20% puisse avoir droit à un
départ un droit automatique au départ
anticipé et considérant que
l'attribution d'un toit 20% voies
médicales définitif pour centre 10 et
15% à 10 et 20% selon la fois beaucoup
simplifié les process administratifs
mais aussi diminuer en passant de 17 à 5
ans la durée d'exposition une situation
pénible telle que c'est prévu par la loi
aujourd'hui pour faciliter des départs
en incapacité pour des personnes qui
sont malheureusement victimes de l'usure
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Gérard le seul
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente
monsieur le ministre chers collègues en
2014 a été créée le C3P le compte
personnel de prévention de la pénibilité
un dispositif bien connu permettant
salarié exposé à des conditions de
travail difficiles de gagner des points
pour financer des formations un temps
partiel sans base de salaire ou encore
un départ à la retraite anticipée en
2017 votre nouvelle majorité a remplacée
donc ce c-3p par le compte professionnel
de prévention C2P mais en plus de la
suppression du mot pénibilité dans la
dénomination elle-même de ce compte
professionnel au lieu de mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité vous en avez
retiré plusieurs critères risquent
chimiques vibrations mécaniques postures
pénible et port de charge lourdes sous
couvert de supprimer une usine à gaz
comme cela a été dit vous avez créé une
usine à Mirage et comme l'évoquer mes
collègues la Cour des comptes
indiquait que le compte professionnel de
prévention est un dispositif voué un
exercice qu'un effet réduit sans impact
sur la prévention et qu'il n'est pas à
la hauteur des objectifs qui lui était
assigné dans un contexte tout l'âge de
départ en retraite recule par ailleurs
les syndicats vous le savez sont opposés
unanima cette réforme des retraites et
sont bien conscients que la pénibilité
au travail est encore loin d'être
reconnue que les dispositifs existantes
étaient affaiblies par votre majorité
depuis 2017 à de très nombreuses
reprises vous avez répété
sûrement pour vous rassurer que votre
texte sur les retraites permettrait une
amélioration de la prise en compte de la
pénibilité il n'en est rien ainsi dans
votre
plfssr vous auriez pu au moins
réintégrer les facteurs de risque
supprimés en 2017 au lieu de cela vous
avez relancé l'usine amirage en évoquant
les retraites à 1200 euros pour tous
alors nous nous opposons à cette réforme
pour préserver des années de vie en
bonne santé pour tous les travailleurs
et en particulier pour ceux qui vivent
de la pénibilité au travail ma question
est double monsieur le ministre alors
que l'ensemble des syndicats s'opposent
à cette réforme des retraites et qu'il
demande la réintégration des critères de
pénibilité quand allez-vous ouvrir le
catalogue social sur les retraites et
sur les pénibilités et quand allez-vous
réintroduire ces critères que vous avez
supprimés je vous remercie par avance je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
vous évoquez la réforme de 2014 c'est
bien celle qui avait augmenté la durée
de cotisation requise pour avoir accès
au taux plein c'est toujours est-il de
rappeler qu'il y a voté cette réforme et
les conditions dans lesquelles se
mettent en place si c'était à refaire
nous ferions la même chose que ce que
nous avons fait en 2017 les trois
critères ergonomiques faisaient dans le
cadre de cette réforme l'objet d'une
quantification individuelle quasi
quotidienne cette émission impossible
notamment pour les entreprises petites
et moyennes et nous avons acté le fait
avec cette réforme et le plfssr que je
présente devant vous restez le fait que
en matière de port de charge de
d'exposition au postures pénible et de
l'exposition vibrations la mesure
totalement individuelle n'est pas
possible d'où le recours à un dialogue
social de bronches et des mesures
collectives de prévention assorties d'un
suivi individuel lui médical renforcé
tel que je l'ai désigné tout à l'heure
ça c'est la première chose que je
voulais souligner la deuxième c'est que
vous pouvez pas dire que le texte nous
permet pas d'améliorer la prise en
compte de la pénibilité quand on
améliore les possibilités qu'on élargit
les possibilités d'obtention de points
qu'on améliore quand valorise la valeur
des points qu'on crée des utilisations
nouvelles de droite et qu'on fait en
sorte que les polyposés soient mieux
pris en compte on améliore ces deux pays
que vous le vouliez ou non c'est une
amélioration et c'est vue comme tel et
quand on fait en sorte que les trois
critères ergonomiques qui avaient été
sortis en 2017 fasse l'objet d'un
nouveau traitement avec les accords de
prévention financiers pour un milliard
d'euros et un suivi médical d'un endroit
à des départs anticipés c'est aussi une
amélioration vous pouvez considérer que
c'est insuffisant mais vous ne pouvez
pas dire que ça ça n'est rien et enfin
je termine sur le dernier critère que
vous avez évoqué celui de l'exposition
risque chimique nous considérons c'est
un parti pris que qui peut être discuter
mais ne considérons que ça ne relève pas
là de la pénibilité en tant que tel ça
relève de la sécurité et l'objectif est
de respecter l'intégralité des normes et
de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
d'exposition en tout cas le moins
souvent possible parce que là aussi il
faut être parfois réaliste par rapport à
la réalité des conditions de travail
mais d'être dans une logique
d'interdiction de l'exposition et de
respect des normes plafonds tels que
définit par la France comme par l'Union
européenne
je vous remercie pour la deuxième série
de questions la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude taureau pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans une société que je
n'appelle pas de mes vœux où on
demanderait sans discernement ou presque
à tout le monde de travailler deux ans
de plus parmi les nombreuses questions
que cela me pose je m'interroge sur les
portes de sortie quand ce sera pour
incapacité permanente il sera déjà trop
tard et ce sera il s'agira d'un échec
cuisant de la prévention
tout à l'heure a été évoqué le besoin de
tant de respiration dans une carrière
mais parfois ce sont des temps de
réorientation qui s'imposent me
semble-t-il ce que la pénibilité ce
n'est pas juste avec son corps même si
souvent c'est lui qui donne le premier
signal d'alerte dans nombreux métiers
les risques d'usure sont peut-être moins
flagrants mais bien réel vous avez
apporté des exemples concrets tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre je vais en
apporter d'autres un professeur 1 ou une
professeur des écoles un ou une
enseignante au bout du rouleau vous en
conviendrez ne sont plus utiles pour
personne qu'elle porte de sortie une
infirmière une aide-soignante est sauvée
par les restructurations les
remplacements liés au manque de
personnel un maçon un travailleur de la
logistique une auxiliaire de vie une
coiffeuse
usée par l'exercice ou les conditions
d'exercices de leur métier des
travailleurs sociaux découragés par la
dureté et l'ampleur de la tâche et le
manque de moyens
donc quelle alternative assis à ce qui
se passe couramment c'est à dire aux
arrêts maladiers à répétition ou au
chômage longue durée vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre un
congé de reconversion avec le maintien
du salaire à 100% à qui s'adressera t-il
s'agit s'agira-t-il d'une liste
restrictive ou plutôt ouverte quand
sera-t-il déclenché
combien de fois et enfin faut-il en
faire un outil central de la formation
tout au long de la vie et repense
également le CET inopérant et objets de
nombreuses dérives
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci Madame
présente monsieur le député peut-être
une réponse en trois points d'abord sur
le congé de reconversion pour vous dire
que nous souhaitons d'une part
qui soit une utilisation de droit pour
les salariés titulaires d'un C2P et
nourri par des points de C2P et dans ce
cas là y compris du fait du
déplafonnement il n'y a pas de limite
sinon d'avoir suffisamment de points
pour pouvoir accéder à cet outil de
reconversion avec financement de la
formation et maintien de la rémunération
ça ça concerne les salariés titulaires
d'un C2P et bien évidemment les branches
dans le cadre des discussions d'accord
de prévention autour des critères
ergonomiques pourront si elles le
souhaitent mais cela relève du dialogue
social inscrire ce type de congés de
reconversion dans les utilisations et
débouchés possibles de ces accords de
prévention ça c'est la première chose et
je pense que ça peut être un outil
central mais c'est un outil central de
reconversion pour des salariés qui sont
exposés à des critères de pénibilité ça
ne couvre pas d'une certaine manière
quand je dis cela des salariés qui ne
sont pas exposés à des critères de
pénibilité quantifiables telles qu'ils
le seront aujourd'hui mais qui peuvent à
moins de leur vie avoir besoin vous
parlez de respiration d'envisager une
reconversion et pour lesquels on doit
aussi faciliter les dispositifs de
transition professionnelle que je
qualifierais droit commun mais c'est un
autre chantier que celui de la
pénibilité plutôt de la formation tout
au long de la vie
deuxième chose c'est que parmi un
certain nombre d'exemples que vous avez
cités il y a des agents publics qui à la
fin de leur carrière peuvent être
fatigués et je dis fatigué plutôt que
c'est parce que ça peut recourir plein
de situations différentes et ne plus
être en mesure de pouvoir faire face à
une activité à temps plein telle qu'il
le font aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous a
amené à prévoir l'ouverture à la
fonction publique du dispositif de
retraite progressive deux ans avant
l'âge de départ des là je d'ouverture
des droits tel qu'il existe dans le
privé nous voulons l'assouplir dans le
privé et le créer dans le public pour
permettre de décélérer sans remettre en
cause la capacité à accueillir à
acquérir des durées de enfin vous avez
parlé du compte épargon si c'est ce que
vous voulez être sûr on a un très beau
chantier je crois qui doit faire l'objet
d'une négociation interprofessionnelle
parce que ça relève de l'article L1 du
Code du travail autour du compte
épargnement universel et de la capacité
à avoir un compte épargne temps pour
chaque salarié qui soit portable d'un
employeur à l'autre pour que
l'utilisation des jours ainsi accumulé
puisse être décidée par les salariés
tout au long de la vie pas uniquement
pendant leur période de salariat ou
d'engagement dans une entreprise
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole
pour le groupe les républicains est à
Monsieur Francis Dubois
oui monsieur le ministre je souhaite
vous interroger sur le statut des
secrétaires de mairie dans les petites
communes notamment en milieu rural
maillon essentiel incontournable de la
vie communale et secrétaire de mairie
sont l'appui technique et juridiques des
maires et participent comme vous le
savez à la mise en œuvre de politique de
l'équipe municipale
c'est un emploi qui nécessite des
compétences multiples finances gestion
des services techniques ressources
humaines etc urbanisme est à civil
organisation des élections et que du
public le secrétaire de mairie doit
ainsi faire preuve d'une grande
adaptabilité de polyvalence
d'organisation et ce d'autant milieu
rural comme angorase par exemple ou très
souvent plusieurs communes se partagent
même secrétaire de mairie cependant
malgré un profil très complet un rôle
décisif dans la bonne vie de la commune
la reconnaissance de cette fonction
n'est pas en adéquation avec les
dispositions statutaires actuelles
l'émission sont mal définies les agents
sur le départ sont systématiquement
remplacés par des adjoines
administratifs des catégories citulée
carrière et rémunération
permettant une refonte des grilles de
salaire n'a pas pu bénéficier secrétaire
de Berry devant la nécessité de mieux
reconnaître ce métier dans un contexte
actuel de tension sur les effectifs et
de vieillissement des agents
une récente proposition de loi
transpartisanes initié par notre
collègue Pierre Morel à l'huissier à
laquelle j'ai apporté ma cosignature
vise à revaloriser le métier de
secrétaire de mairie ce texte propose de
faire évoluer l'appellation de cette
profession en responsable de
l'administration communale et de créer
un statut d'emploi comprenant deux
grilles indiciaires il propose également
pour pallier aux difficultés de
recrutement d'élargir la possibilité
pour les communes de recruter des agents
contractuels en relevant le plafond
démographique en deçà duquel se
recrutement est ouvert de 1000 à 2000
habitants il envisage aussi la mise en
œuvre avec le lien
avec le
CNFPT pardon de formation spécifique
dans ton titre de la prise de poste ces
formations seraient en effet très utile
en particulier pour les contractuels
recrutés en conséquence je vous demande
monsieur le ministre en equestre
initiative parlementaire soutenu sur le
terrain votre ministère entend revoir
les statuts de secret de mairie des
petites communes et si c'est décisions
seront prochainement prises en vue afin
d'assurer une pleine reconnaissance à ce
métier je vous remercie merci Monsieur
ministre vous avez la parole on
s'éloigne un peu du champ de la
pénibilité monsieur le député mais plus
sérieusement cette question statue des
agents communaux et notamment des
sauvetats de mairies relèvent très
directement de mon collègue Stanislas
Guérini en charge la fonction publique
et de ma collègue Dominique Faure en
charge des collectivités j'aurais pu
vous répondre il y a quatre ans quand
j'étais en charge la fonction publique
mais là ça dépasse vraiment très
largement et c'est très extérieur à mon
champ de compétence ministérielle je ne
connais pas le détail de la proposition
transpartizane que vous avez évoqué mais
impossible pour moi de me prononcer même
si comme vous étant élu d'un département
rural et une circonscription avec 89
communes je sais la difficulté et des
mères pour recruter et des secrétaires
de mairie pour assurer des tâches qui
souvent sont multiformes sur plusieurs
lieux et avec une multiplication de
temps partiel parfois dans des toutes
petites communes et des élus qui
comptent beaucoup beaucoup sur eux et si
je veux dire sur elle parce que c'est
une profession qui est aussi extrêmement
féminisée donc je pense que mon collègue
Stanislas Guérini qui vous rejoint tout
à l'heure pourra peut-être vous répondre
je ne peux pas sortir de mon périmètre
comme ça sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le ministre et la parole
est à Monsieur Sébastien bettavi pour le
groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
il est pénible finalement d'avoir enfin
d'entendre depuis trois semaines de
renvoyé à chaque fois une future loi
travail qui arrivera après la loi
retraite et il y a quand même beaucoup
d'éléments là-dedans qui nous auraient
permis de d'être éclairé sur justement
comment
[Musique]
envisager les départs anticipés ou pas à
la retraite
nous avons je regrette également que
vous n'ayez pas été présent lors des
témoignages
d'une aide à domicile et d'un paysan
tout à l'heure alors j'ai cru tant que
vous étiez pas loin vous avez pu
entendre ce qu'il y avait été dit mais
ça aurait été bien que vous ayez pu être
présent là
à côté
pour reprendre un petit peu leur
témoignage alors
ce qui m'a marqué dans leur témoignage
c'est que nous avons deux professions
qui sont isolées dans l'exercice
[Musique]
de leur profession et qui se retrouvent
avec une grande attente que ce soit et
pour nourrir
tous les citoyens français et pour
pouvoir accompagner des personnes
fragiles soit parce que âgés soit avec
une situation de handicap
les deux ont pu relever que finalement
la médecine du travail avait énormément
de difficultés à pouvoir reconnaître
tous les soucis de santé qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer il y a quand même chez les
paysans un taux de suicide qui est
assez terrible et que l'on entend à
chaque fois et devant laquelle on se
retrouve
moi pour venir d'une circonscription
très rurale il y a quand même quelque
chose qui à chaque fois et est terrible
d'entendre ces situations pour une aide
à domicile quand on voit les temps
partiels subis et des amplitudes
horaires très importantes
et avec l'impossibilité parce qu'on voit
comment est renvoyé à chaque fois cette
idée de
d'avoir par exemple des lèvres malades
et il y a des choses qui ne peuvent pas
être mis en place à domicile donc
comment ces choses là concrètement
peuvent être mises en place pour
ces deux témoignages là et ensuite pour
conclure
oui très vite vous évoquez cette visite
médicale autour de 40 ans pour réfléchir
à partir de là une réorientation c'est
quand même dommage d'attendre que les
corps soient abîmés pour pouvoir leur en
trouver un autre
usage merci merci pour vous répondre
monsieur betavie sur la forme parce que
d'autres collègues se sont posés la
question ça n'est pas la pratique ça n'a
jamais été la pratique d'ailleurs que le
ministre soit présent au moment de la
Table Ronde c'est son des débats qui
sont construits en deux phases voilà
peut-être qu'il faut faire évoluer mais
c'est effectivement c'est la tradition
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci
je m'étais contenté de suivre par écran
interposé soit moi directement soit sur
mes équipes et que je ne voyais pas de
frustration à parler d'une loi travail
qui arrive puisque c'est la perspective
de d'avoir des débats nouveaux sur ces
sujets là et de vous retrouver les uns
les autres dans l'hémicycle ou en
commission sur les deux questions que
vous avez évoquées vous avez raison sur
les aides à domicile c'est un secteur
très particulier et ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure comme exemple de
différenciation sur l'exposition aux
conditions à l'usure professionnelle
pour les aides-soignants des pannes avec
ou sans rail d'une manière très
simpliste ne vaut pas pour le domicile
ou très rarement puisque le niveau
d'équipement à domicile évidemment moins
important que dans les établissements
donc c'est un énorme travail qui nous
font mener pour voir comment et avec les
partenaires sociaux de ce secteur les
conditions de travail des aides à
domicile peuvent être améliorés dire
comment comme ça je ne sais pas en
réalité et je pense que si quelqu'un
avait la solution la plus magique la
plus efficace et la plus rapide tout le
monde serait très heureux de pouvoir
mettre un homme et c'est un énorme
chantier sur les questions relatives à
l'agriculture vous avez notamment évoqué
l'isolement et la question des suicides
je crois qu'il y a une mission qui est
en cours qui confie à Monsieur le noir
et qui doit rendre ses conclusions
bientôt puisque cette mission a été
initiée il y a un tout petit peu plus
d'un an donc j'imagine qu'elle arrive au
bout de ce travail là il y a quelques
préconisations qui sont d'ores et déjà
cette notamment sur le fait de désigner
ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
sentinelles pour permettre de prévenir
au maximum ce risque de ce risque de
suicide je fais une association d'idées
entre la profession d'agriculteur les
difficultés y compris en termes de
risque psychosociaux et d'exposition à
l'usure
pour dire que dans le cadre de du texte
que j'ai présenté devant vous il y a
quelques jours maintenant il y a une
disposition qui va permettre d'améliorer
la situation de retraités actuel de
l'agriculture je parle d'exploitant
agricole donc d'indépendant et les
futurs retraités je m'explique en un mot
les deux lois porté par André Chassagne
prévoit donc une garantie de retraite
minimum dès lors que les exploitants
agricoles ont réalisé une carrière
complète sauf qu'il y a un seront
d'exploitants agricoles qui ne peuvent
aller tout à fait au bout de leur
carrière parce que justement l'usure les
amène à un départ anticipé pour
incapacité et les exploitants agricoles
qui partent de manière anticipée pour
incapacité son privé de l'accès à la
garantie deschassagne et donc dans le
plfssr il y a une disposition qui dit
que sera réputé complète la carrière
d'un exploitant agricole partie de
manière anticipée pour une question
d'incapacité sur le seul sur les seules
retraités actuels sans présumer du flux
mais sur les seuls ce sont 45 000
retraités actuels qui ne disposent qui
ne bénéficient pas de la garantie
Chassagne et qui vont voir leur
situation requalifiée et disposer de
cette garantie avec une
amélioration moyenne de 80-85 euros par
pension sachant que l'amélioration
moyenne de la loi Chassagne dite
Chassagne 1 était autour d'une centaine
d'euros aussi donc on est à peu près
dans les mêmes niveaux et c'est une
correction que nous apportons pour
permettre une meilleure prise en compte
de ces situations
merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues le débat est maintenant clos
je vais suspendre trois minutes le temps
de d'installer la prochaine table ronde
pour le débat suivant